two
what is up my beautiful people
song in my heart today because it's
Wednesday thank you Lena September 21st
here is Ethan Klein off the rails hello
[Music]
podcast hello number one number one
number one
[Music]
show together
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]
we got them
wow we got him
oh you got me in a little I want to get
canceled
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
wow
[Music]
dog
[Applause]
I just I just my ego just died
[Music]
[Music]
wow
foreign
just had ego death only just me no no I
I am I forgot who I was or I'm in the
astral plane right now my dude
wow another Masterpiece uh collaboration
between I would assume Zach and Ian yes
great um
visuals uh great audio what a journey
thank you I think that's what they say
happens uh when Haley Bobbitt comes
around if you drink the Kool-Aid and
kill yourself that's basically what you
see in the afterlife some Jim Jones [ __ ]
Haley Bobbitt huh
Haley Bobbitt what's the name of the
actual comment yeah ridiculous name hell
Bob
Wayne Bobbitt yeah exactly
anyways guys welcome there's a heck of
an episode here today A lot going on
sponsored by gamer sup rise up Gamers
it's gamer sub Nation
dude I'm gamer sup Army right now this
this stuff keeps me flying through the
show that's right and of course hella
fresh we all love so well thank you
um today yesterday was
I don't know how many of you are like
super in touch with twitch
um
I'm more so now because we're of a
Hassan my friendship with Hassan
um Love is also really into twitch so he
kind of Keeps Us appraised I guess you
are too in it right
uh as you mentioned kind of just through
the association right well for those of
you who didn't see it twitch had a
complete and total meltdown slash Civil
War
yesterday I I don't I mean I can
I can compare it to like drama getting
on YouTube when like tati went after
James and Jeffrey but it is this I guess
it's not it's as crazy as that I would
say I mean that was pretty insane that
time yeah probably I think maybe like
it's a niche thing because drama get him
for some reason it felt like the whole
world knew about it
um but yeah I think in terms of how
significant well this one has like
threads of corruption the threads of
crimes and then twitch ultimately in the
midst of everything melting down
putting out an announcement that they're
banning
gambling on Twitch which is great news
obviously
uh as someone me who's been advocating
for that for a long time if you go way
back even to the shack
that's right steak Shack
um oh by the way what's up Tick Tock
what's up my tater tots W snakeo let's
get sneakers in the chat no hey tick
talkers my tater tots come try it out
you know I'm Reaching Across the aisle
I'll I'll say I hate women whatever you
want just come over and give it a shot
yeah hey guys I hate women man they suck
all right come check it out from Death
to life I don't actually hate women
don't tell Tick Tock [ __ ] I respect
women
so we're going to get into that
um
they sure do wow that's so true dude
that was a prophetic moment there and uh
the uh
uh what was it the fat Professor
yeah he's nutty he's not fat he's nutty
yeah
and then after that
at around 2 30 2 15.
what time is he coming like 2 30. 2 30.
young gravy at long last the musical
Genius of young gravy will be joining us
in an hour to discuss
all the gravy he'd be uh spreading
around spreading he'd be spreading that
gravy and I'm here for it gravy bases me
up like a turkey Daddy
um I have a question do you guys like it
better hat or no hat because my hair is
pretty unkempt and long the Hat I feel
it fits my head kind of weird
I like no hat no hat got your hand
yeah dudes yes Cameron in his uh
Cameron Cameron became the the bat
rabbit or whatever it is yeah it used to
be but now I fully am again
hmm cute all right well let's do it
let's just get into it we have so much
to talk about for pizza's sake
um
yes so basically one thing I wanted to
show you guys before we get started
ultimately is tomorrow
uh September 22nd
new Teddy fresh collections dropping at
teddyfresh.com actually really nice
stuff here let me check this out that's
hot so this sweater is dope but what's
even it looks great I love it it's 100
recycled material 100 percent
which is a new vertical we're getting
into obviously
um
it's super important to start investing
more in recycled fabrics and this was
kind of our first entry in but 100
recycled oh that's hot so yeah pretty
exciting pretty cool
uh it's just a cool shirt
vibes
thank you
hoodie Vibes thank you next this is the
sweater Eva was wearing Vibes thank you
next
overalls Vibes thank you
hat
yeah this is a collab with some really
cool artists that we did
sweater Vibes sweater Vibes check oh my
Noble Knight
a beautiful uh
what do you call that pug
no but like the technique it's like uh
it's like sewn on a tapestry or
something yeah it's really cool my Noble
Knight indeed
bags cool ass shirts with a really cool
artist whose Name Escapes me we'll talk
about it more tomorrow but anyway
tomorrow 10 a.m PST
it's all coming out so thank you to
Teddy fresh
thank you to ELA
before we get started there's some
things I just need to address
excuse me what the [ __ ] is this Zach you
guys got you guys got blitzed by this
Tic Tac dude who's like yo I love your
bag uh tell me what you do for a living
or whatever yeah was this 100 real 100
real because I always assume these guys
fake it I thought that too until this
[ __ ] happened but look how Chantelle
is so weirded out she wants nothing to
do with him
we're in the adult entertainment
business oh okay what do you guys do
exactly
I don't know you don't want to know
excuse me I like her Blends dude dude
you knew that [ __ ] was gonna end up on
the show didn't you honestly no I
because
last time someone stuck a camera in our
face it was went out we were Jimmy Lee
and you know I won't get into it but
I've been on edge since that so drama
this [ __ ] just out of nowhere is
like hey I love your back what do you do
you know like so like I'm going into
defense mode and I'm like okay is this
guy [ __ ] with me is he like being
genuine like what is going on and
Chantal didn't like it no I could tell
but it's not really polite to just slam
a camera in someone's face and be like
yo tell me everything absolutely not so
it's like all right [ __ ] this guy like
just throw him a little bit
yeah you got them good I mean you made
it you were the first one in and all the
comments are about you too which is
awesome yeah shout out to H3 family and
all those Foot Soldiers by the way happy
birthday Nick Piper 30th love you for
that
forever okay we need you we love you
even even the top comment is people
riding for you who don't even know who
you are
you don't want to know okay now we
really do want to know so Zach now's
your chance
uh no I was just trolling it's a joke
yeah it's a joke right yeah
yeah
although there was at one point a
significant other of yours I don't know
what you're talking about right right
right right right that never happened
yeah Zach was yeah no that never
happened
um anyway so congratulations on being
featured there
good times huh
Good Times
is that a bad Vibe what I did oh you're
good man
it's not fair that I have to forget that
app
you know what I mean it's not fair it's
not it's not fair that I have to forget
about it anyways uh somebody donated a
hundred dollars
100 snackaroons for Ian and Zach intro
as a masterpiece we got wait I don't
even see it on here oh there it comes
or just tell me I'll send them the money
uh you know just just write their names
down y'all need to stop I pay them just
for the record I do pay they do pay them
but it's
it's not a good way
to do it let's just put it that way but
thank you thank you why don't you guys
put your crypto wallets like eat girls
right or something they're also on Cameo
you could support them there there you
go for everyone yeah they'll get they'll
get five percent of the revenue
yeah anyway thank you for the donuts
yeah thank you very much
can you can you shorten it up there in
your your uh
hello
a short but decent first time for me oh
this one was good actually so
this is another [ __ ] up edit where
they spliced the audio together in the
just horrific way
this one is not having to do with Disney
or Marvel though I don't think that was
Halloween so check this out this one's
really good
it will be difficult to say goodbye to
Laurie Strode that one's really good it
would be difficult to say goodbye too
Lori Strode goodbye to Laurie Strode
in the Marvel Universe
Laurie Strode I don't know why these
things tickle me it would be difficult
to say goodbye to Laura Strode
yeah shut up that's it you know a little
top of the show ghost Road all right
let's get into this drama because we
don't have unlimited time to talk about
this
um
also Hassan's gonna be here tomorrow
leftovers is back all right he
is in the center of all this drama in
the eye of the storm
um so we're gonna have a lot to talk to
him about but
I guess get started I'm gonna try my
best here to summarize everything
it started with mizkiff and Pokey
[Music]
making a joint statement telling twitch
to stop
to ban gambling right I mean it's in the
wake of
this huge Scandal we talked about on uh
Monday this one guy slick slicker
was sending out DMS to fans and fellow
streamers asking them for money to feed
his gambling addiction he was lying to
them he was frauding them
interesting side note he's still on
Twitch baby he didn't get he didn't even
get in trouble for that it's awesome at
least he was as of last night let me
check again because I feel like that's
got to be coming but
yeah for you guys that don't know he was
just he it was like real bottom of the
barrel [ __ ] like he even stole money
from a cancer patient who needed it for
a procedure and he's like yo I need this
money I'll hit you back I promise my
bank account got yeah he was live two
days ago so shout out to the legend
there you go good stuff no clue why they
didn't ban him for that bizarre but
anyway so here so here's the what
started this whole uh drum apocalypse I
would totally if if someone said Ms
signed this right now and we're going to
not stream for a whole week I would say
can we do longer I would I would totally
be down I'll say look I'll take someone
else's time too
I mean otk and Pokey alone you guys
could probably move mountains
if you got asthma on but as we would
love a week off too bad
yo Charlie idea of doing it Q4 around
Christmas too because that'll hurt the
most
yeah yeah it would because that's when
they need the uh the ads yeah yeah
so they're talking about staging like a
walkout or something where they don't
stream for a week
hmm to try to uh pressure twitch into
Banning gambling it's a good thing I
mean it's a great thing right
here's the thing a train wreck who's a
giant piece of [ __ ] which I'll prove to
you guys today
we've talked about him a lot he is
basically it's train wreck and xqc are
the main gamblers
who work with steak which is basically
like a unregulated crypto Casino located
in a shack offshore
super Shady
that's right anyway so he his whole
livelihood is being threatened he says
because your pals decided it was in
their best interest to use and platform
the very person that scammed everyone
for his horse racing and Tennis bets to
somehow twist it and wager the war
against me and we both know deep down
why the insecure little man is doing
this
so he's going well this guy was a
gambling addict but he was doing uh
sports betting so
so it's got nothing to do with me I just
do slots
misk have said if we're going to deep
platform people for scamming others
shouldn't we have banned you for jolt
coin a few years back I don't know
anything about jolt coin but that seems
like a pretty good this
what was that about train wreck scamming
crypto [ __ ]
certain certainly wouldn't surprise me
well anyway this is when it all really
gets crazy
train wreck responds
are you going to send Maya and Mitch to
Railroad and blackmail me like you did
those girls to cover up all those sexual
assaults you [ __ ] scumbag piece of
[ __ ] you want to come at me and make
[ __ ] up then you better be sure you
don't live in a glass house you insecure
[ __ ]
oh
now let me ask you guys this
so this this accusation ended up
ballooning into like a huge developing
story let me ask you guys this
is this the right way to bring up
this kind of serious allegation
like
um
he's using it in retaliation
he's saying
because it wasn't even his first
response
he's like yeah well if you're going to
try to shut down my livelihood then I'm
gonna like
accuse you of blackmailing someone like
he if he cared about it
seriously
he would have brought it up in a serious
setting not like a gotcha
to come up over on Mischief right I mean
this is so [ __ ] tacky
in my opinion
this is a man that's fighting for his
livelihood makes ungod-known amounts of
millions of dollars a month to hook
people to gambling
also he says he says to him you don't
live in a glass house so he's like
you know that metaphor is like if you
live in a glass house don't throw stones
and so he's he's saying uh straight up
um
if you talk [ __ ] about me I'll break
your house so he's saying up front it's
a retaliatory statement
now I'm not speaking to the validity
of what he's saying which we'll get into
obviously but I'm just saying super
scummy in my opinion that was my initial
thought
and it's still what I think about train
wreck is that the way he brought this up
was like super [ __ ] up
again not question that has nothing to
do with the validity of of what he's
saying it's something we'll continue to
discuss but am I wrong like the way he
brought that up was just so [ __ ]
insane yeah I mean it's just a crazy
deflection
I'm sorry like
I know people were debating if how how
is it even debatable the way he brought
this up was so [ __ ] up
I'm sorry
it just is like well you can't argue
with how effective it was because
immediately this became the entire
conversation and not the gambling
anymore so mission accomplished I guess
it worked everyone's saying Ethan you
have no idea what you're talking about
I'm sorry this is not the way you bring
up serious allegations if he was serious
about it he should have done it in a
serious way
I'm sorry like again not talking about
the validity but this is super scummy of
him I'm not gonna let him act like he's
the [ __ ] good guy because he
weaponized some really serious [ __ ] in a
moment to deflect against his gambling
gambling Scandal now we can get into the
validity of it but I feel like
and I'm mental bro I'm mental
because people are defending him and the
fact that it's effective is like
who gives a [ __ ] I mean that's that's a
separate conversation also you're you're
implying that he's playing like 5D chess
like he knew that all of a sudden people
were gonna care about this that's not
what happened you could tell he did this
emotionally he did it angrily this
wasn't calculated he just did a [ __ ]
up thing he goes
you scumbag piece of [ __ ] if you want to
come at me that I'm gonna come at you
like you know this isn't this isn't a
delicately put
a well-thought-out statement this is
emotional and angry
he goes if you're going to come at me
then I'm going to come at you you
insecure [ __ ] I'm sorry but train wreck
I'm not gonna let him be the good guy
for bringing it up like this I mean this
is just [ __ ] insane sorry it is and
like there's just there's been this
online dialogue about like
so uh uh what train did was like he's
the man and he brought this up because
train wreck and xqc started going after
Pokey and Hassan
because they weren't taking it serious
enough I'm telling you I'm going to get
into it but it was so [ __ ] up I'm
telling you guys train wreck is such a
scumbag and I'm going to show you guys
exactly how so just remember that this
idiot broke the news like this and I
really don't care what anyone else says
the victim is on train wreck's side
she says it's fine the way he did it
that's okay right like she's welcome to
have that opinion my opinion is I'm not
questioning the validity of of whatever
she said happened
she's welcome to have an opinion it's
home and my opinion is okay this is not
this is [ __ ] up he obviously did this
emotionally he obviously did this
retaliatory he this wasn't a calculated
move I'm sorry I'm not going to pretend
like it is and walk on eggshells because
somehow people are going to misconstrue
me saying trainwreck's a piece of [ __ ]
with me questioning the validity because
the victim thinks it was fine the way he
did it that's fine we're all she's
entitled to have her opinion I'm not
questioning the validity I'm just saying
trainwreck's a piece of [ __ ] and this
was [ __ ] up thank you let's move on
all right so that happened
um
so after he tweeted this it was revealed
that mizkiff's roommate crazy slick
and a streamer named Adriana
the story was that
Adriana was at their house the otk house
he's got like a streaming Clan
can I call it a clan or is that like
antiquated
it's a little Boomer
although Facebook plan they're still
around that's what I thought we we
rolled in Clan it was always Clans back
in the day I I yeah I guess they're
just to be super detailed that is not
the otk house it's just his house um the
people living there are not all the
notifications thank you thank you yes
yeah
um so it was revealed that
mischief's good buddy and roommates
crazy slick he went in to check on this
girl Adriana when she was drunk and
passed out
he went in to check on her
and then he actually groped her instead
and I've learned about this guy crazy
slick that he's like a real nasty
[ __ ] dude with lots of accusations
against him so like
a hundred percent believe that's what
happened especially when you look at who
this guy is there's like a whole thread
of people talking about what a creepy is
dirty Dom Vibes total dirty Dom Vibes
and what's [ __ ] up about it
because I definitely decide I'm on her
side all the way right she put together
a thread with like all these other girls
sending DMS and sharing their stories
about him it's like endless which if
you're interested is there I read
through it and I was like man this guy
[ __ ] sucks
and so
as I understand it
at the time apparently this was I don't
know how long ago
um
one of uh Adriana's friends said that
someone at that house had assaulted her
and then when it became public and
people started under being like yo what
the [ __ ] you guys need to talk about
this
um mizkiff and his girlfriend
at the time girlfriend at the time
went to her
and basically said like yo uh
what what happened here is this SEC like
sexual assault or what and she I think
felt pressured or coerced to say
basically that uh nothing happened she's
a small streamer they're massive
streamers they're friends
not that nothing happened but to
downplay to say that it wasn't us it
didn't necessarily rise to the level of
assault which he no longer feels that
way and I guess didn't feel that way at
the time and felt pressured to frame it
that way El beta Ethan what's up tater
tots I hate women man [ __ ] man women
suck
love you Tater Tots it's police sub
anyway so I was talking to tick tock a
bunch of tater tots shut up
yeah even Maya Miss kipp's ex-girlfriend
who's being accused she put out a video
saying like
when she said that she didn't think she
was assaulted Maya said specifically
well then include that in your statement
and I can see her interpreting that as
like uh coercion or pressure that made
her uncomfortable right
well it came out I guess
that uh she does feel like she was
assaulted and basically he did grope her
now she's saying okay
um here's the original statement she
made in a 20 2012 I don't know yeah he's
a twit longer
she says basically that's
um it didn't rise to uh
she says here just to paraphrase to be
clear he did not r word me or assault me
but his actions did make me
uncomfortable
so I can see her point when she's like
it this dude may be really uncomfortable
and then Maya's like say it was not
assault and the thing
so I totally get
uh where she felt pressured
here's a clip describing how she said
she felt pressured besides the point my
point was Maya was like um
you should say anything at all and I'm
like are you [ __ ] kidding me or she
said I should say something anonymously
or everyone was like no or or I should
say it wasn't that big of a deal and I'm
over it now I was like listen I'm gonna
be true to myself I'll make slick look
good like like an angel because I did in
the Tweet longer if anybody ever
bothered to read it because a lot of
people didn't
um I makes like look like an angel I'm
like hey it's whatever it's made me
uncomfortable but it's whatever even
though I was upset with it I just you
know
I came to uh even point with Maya
because it seems like there was you know
some some pressure direct or indirect of
of people wanting her to downplay it for
the sake of their friend their roommate
I don't know if they had business
relations with him
so yeah that's that sh that [ __ ]
happened for sure
um
net then the worst part comes
when there's this old clip of mizkiff
talking about it and Miss Kiff if you
guys he's one of the biggest streamers
on the platform right I mean he's a he's
like connected with everyone he's a big
deal right love
yes yeah he is yeah and he's like the
founder of otk which is this big gamer
conglomerate
so someone found this old clip of Miss
Kiff after the story broke and it was
pretty foul what he says here so let's
listen
he hates that there's a narrative about
him being creepy I yeah
sucks
I told them I'm like look you didn't
rape anybody you know it's one thing
I feel like
I mean like I didn't do anything
he didn't
very dystopian Watching This World of
Warcraft I know I know like the lion
jumping around it seemed like he did so
[ __ ] weird
this is Twitch for you man
this is entertainment
like
when people like think of it they think
that he stuck his [ __ ] dick inside
her
without her consent
and I'm like
that's what people perceive it as
when they don't people probably don't
even know the situation
no it's not
it's not 90 of people look I I don't
think there's a single person that we
used to hang out with that doesn't hang
out with slick anymore because of what
happened I actually think there's
literally none because the reality is
worse comes the worst of it it's [ __ ]
like sexual harassment right
I mean like who get like no one of what
you can deem of it it's sexual
harassment whatever
at a low scale it's not really a big
deal I don't think people really gave a
[ __ ] and really cared so I'm gonna turn
this off if you're gonna be like this
yeah I mean obviously
it sounds so pretty bad yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] actual assault at a low scale
nobody gives it nobody cares well even
yeah nobody cared even past tense like
this is because this was in I guess 2019
or something
no oh maybe or I don't know I know it
was recent it's in 20 uh 20 2012 which
is what you said earlier
20 20 21. you meant to say 2021 you said
20 2012. yeah it's been when did I say
that a few minutes ago oh yeah yeah go
to Joe
303 Street oh did it make anyone
uncomfortable by the way and I don't
know I'm sure this is maybe just a
semantical thing but when he said it's
not like he put his penis in or he what
did how did he phrase it it was graphic
in a way it didn't have to be yeah it
made me really
it's like it's not like he forced his
penis into her vagina or something I
don't know it just made me feel kind of
gross don't talk about
don't talk about it yeah don't talk
about it talk about like that like you
know in graphic detail but there it is
okay whatever
so that happened so this thing is
brewing man and let's remember
this all started because mizkiff and
Pokey were trying to
put some support together for a protest
against twitch gambling
train wreck
probably is the single Mo biggest
beneficiary of twitch gambling
and then all all of a sudden
he turned this into a conversation about
how mizkiff covered up
low-scale sexual harassment I love that
that's like my new fave it's just
low-scale sexual harassment bro
thanks it's on a low scale
um what is low-scale sexual like breathe
on her boobs then touch but just breathe
done
no right maybe let's not even think
about it huh oh there it is
that's a low-scale sexual harassment
right there
so um and then I used to put side in
this guy's a [ __ ] idiot too man
I guess miskiff used to cruise with them
and then ice beside him posted like
screenshots of him saying I think we
could oh you're late yeah yeah he used
to be ice Poseidon's camera man this is
from like 2018 he's like Mischief I
brought you into the throne now I'm
taking you out and he posted like
screenshots of him saying like the
n-word in DMS and stuff
which is like I get that that's [ __ ]
up obviously but ice Poseidon is like
such a douche come on bro like
everyone's just you know talk about
disingenuous criticism coming from him
like he doesn't care that he said the
n-word
you mean ice Poseidon doesn't care ice
Poseidon doesn't care at all
right it's like he just knows that
there's people out there that do care
it's disingenuous criticism but okay I
mean obviously that's [ __ ] up
it seems to me that he's kind of
whatever so yeah that happened
um so Maya responded Ms Kiff responded
I want to get to the point where
xqc and train wreck start debating [ __ ]
with Hassan
so here now that the conversation is off
gambling
and onto this essay cover-up here's
train and xqc tap dancing on his grave
rejoicing
that this man who was once
trying to stop gambling which is a great
thing is now the conversation has
totally shifted but there's a by that
there's nothing in terms of also become
a nice little thing before right no good
side
and then should you tell about the case
in sale and release
um
just ties just like a timing thing I
know why people get souls cup about that
I know why people are so caught up
extension of weaponizing this
well that bro it's a it's a weapon like
what the [ __ ]
it's not a weapon like it's her story
that should be taken seriously when you
use it as a weapon you delegitimize it
to an extent because because
it's its own story it's not it becomes a
subplot
when you weaponize it for yourself
you're taking that narrative away from
her like I don't I don't
know all of these people talking like
it's it's all men talking about someone
else's circumstance that is probably
feels so singular and like so painful
and the way train he trained brought it
up to serve his own interests yes he
didn't bring it up as an act of altruism
that's that's what I'm getting at like
now she says she's friendly with them
she's they've all been on calls together
him and Trey and have been on Call of
scheming and she says you know don't
she's been saying for the record
not to give train an xqc [ __ ] and that
she supports the way they did it yeah
again I'm not questioning the validity
of her claims I believe her but I
disagree yeah I think it's because
nobody listened to her last time and so
these people are willing to help her
because everybody left her in the dark
before right and this is the time that
they're helping her so obviously yeah I
totally I totally get that yeah but
that's a great Point yeah I'm free to
make my own interpretation without
questioning the validity of her claims
again I believe her of course but they
used it as a weapon to serve their own
interests obviously like let's not
[ __ ] pretend that's not what happened
here well in their own words he
literally said yeah and let me back it
up here because they go on to debate
Hassan and pogi which I think is great
and I just want everyone to know what
xqc said about it initiative and sale
and release it
um
just like a timing thing I know why
people get souls caught up about that
why are you guys so colorful
extension of weaponizing this
bro it's a it's a weapon like what the
[ __ ] are you serious it's a weapon
you don't just put that in the vault and
wait until it's opportunistic for you to
use it like do you not understand that's
[ __ ] up I mean I'm like in crazy world
he says there's more too but he's gonna
hold it for another day great perfect
what a guy
there's more but I'm just holding it
over these guys so they don't ever come
at me again that's exactly the perfect
way to handle a serious story with
serious ramifications that you obviously
care about
yeah yeah he's like bro I'm a huge dude
I support her man her story means
everything uh there's a lot more I'm
gonna save it to keep you guys in check
super uh super genuine
saving information for the most
opportunity time
oh I get the most value out of it yeah
[ __ ] it yeah that's what we did what
about it
yeah you're right we were saving the
trump card for a rainy day it got it's
not a trump card bro
this is he's he's and he's giving it
away
he's given the whole game away
it's scum dude Rainey came out okay and
and what's the rain by the way them
trying to get gambling banned on Twitch
that's the rainy day
that's the rainy day
you get that yeah
somebody in the chat just said wasn't
the story about gambling LOL exactly and
that's exactly the point is now it's not
mission accomplished if that was the
rainy day right and so again I have to
untangle all this to talk about it but I
do think it's important to untangle it
because
train wreck and X you see Sid did such a
good job at at throwing mud on this
situation and obfuscating this the facts
of everything that I do think that it's
worth I feel passionate about
[Music]
untangling this to the point where we
can separate the two incidences
and really see what train wreck and xqc
did all in the interest by the way of
keeping gambling
allowed on Twitch that's what they're
fighting for guys the Valiant fight
to allow gambling slot machines on
Twitch my friends stand up for what you
believe in
somebody's somebody got outed as a
deviant who does weird [ __ ] and you
continue to continued from what I've
seen in the logs on this Gordon who
continued to be a weirdo okay and there
was an opportunity and it happened why
the [ __ ] are you so [ __ ] mauled about
dude you're admitting it I'm sorry but
I didn't like xqc or train wreck but
after this I genuinely feel that these
two dudes are [ __ ] terrible people
really terrible really terrible people I
mean this is not state to actually just
say that
and there's actually just so much more
so there's that
okay now this is this is what's really
weird
is that Hassan and uh Pokey
we're also working to get
gambling band
and so they start getting a lot of [ __ ]
because get this they didn't react
appropriately
to train Rex Tweet now let me show you
what it is
uh that they're being criticized for
okay
you're going to send Maya and Mitch
you did those girls to
control assaults you [ __ ] scumbag
piece of [ __ ]
up then you better be sure you don't
live in a glass house you inscript I'm
lost I don't even holy [ __ ]
are you going to send Maya Mission
railroad the black man like dude all
those girls cover up the sexual assaulty
wait what does it means then you better
be sure you don't live in a glass house
you insecure [ __ ] I literally just read
it
railroad him
I don't know what the [ __ ] now to
further
muddy the water xqc
and train wreck managed to get them on a
call
and accuse them of not believing the
victim and not taking this accusation
serious enough when they read it when by
the way it's of course train wrecks
fault a hundred percent that nobody
takes it seriously because of the way
that he introduced it it's confusing
it's vague it's brought up in a
retaliatory nature
and they managed to get these guys on
the back foot once again moving the
conversation off gambling and and and
actually forcing them in in a sense to
apologize for not taking the accusation
more seriously when of course it is 100
train wrecks fault if anybody read this
and didn't take it seriously by the way
it's not that they didn't even take it
seriously they're just shocked and how
the [ __ ] else are you supposed to
respond without any context
brought up like this like even the way
he words it it makes it sound like
mizkiff was the one who was sexually
assaulting people so like it's even
further like confusing the situation
which I think he later clarified in a
later tweet but their reaction just
reading this initial tweet they're
understandably confused because he's
talking about it as if this was like
some known thing
um it's and when it's not really clear
what it also just comes out of nowhere
they're talking about gambling right
and then trains like oh well you well if
you live in a glass house so [ __ ] you
[ __ ] remember when you covered up it's
like dude
um how else are they supposed to respond
the whole effort by train wreck and XGC
is 100 in bad faith they are weaponizing
a really serious story of essay and
they're actually weaponizing
that against Hassan and Pokey who
actually care about a good thing which
is Banning gambling on Twitch
they managed to turn a lot of people
against them and to literally force them
in the corner to apologize for this clip
when really it's train wreck they should
be apologizing for this [ __ ] pure
scumbag move pure
scum
gum bro
the dude is scum
uh we'll get into all that yeah further
now and let me put it this way if there
was like a serious post
maybe they did it in in a conjunction
where trains like yo I'm with my friend
Adriana and we want to talk about this
serious thing Hassan is going to take
that absolutely seriously pokey's gonna
take that absolutely seriously so how
[ __ ] dare you guys accuse them who by
the way are excellent Advocates let's
not even pretend like Hassan's like a
shitty dude and doesn't care about
[ __ ] like uh women coming forward I
mean these These are good Advocates like
who the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] now all of a
sudden you care has trained ever spoken
up about this the only thing you care
about is making [ __ ] money selling
gambling on Twitch you liar [ __ ] scum
despise that man dude such a bad faith
Punk dude the whole time I was just
pulling my hair out because like
the whole thing made no sense how it
twisted against Pokey and Hassan
so we're going to continue now
um
so people start calling out them for not
having a strong enough reaction
here's xqc celebrating because Hassan is
getting Heat
for not reacting strong enough
to the tweet that xuc said quote was
weaponized
hey I son
isn't that the guy when he heard the
news I think
he started to downplay it because he
taught the public opinion he did not
downplay it you [ __ ] liar
let me back him up
already where did he where did he
downplay it he's a [ __ ] liar didn't
happen literally didn't happen
it's like backpedaling it and started
going with we thought it was going to be
public opinion because they had no
knowledge of the situation and it got
absolutely smoked oh he didn't downplay
it okay did he really investigate and it
didn't really inquire
it's like bro what do you expect like I
think this happened just after
this was all happening at the same time
right
um
scum dude I'm telling you man these guys
I'm somehow I don't know how it works
but these two guys who are advocating
for gambling are just don't seem like
good dudes
she's so weird how that happens
you know
I don't think xqc's a good dude either
sorry I'm just gonna say that
um excuse here's a collection of his
comments around the time when people
were calling out Hassan and Pokemon
which seems so insane to me
so this is his chat log what does that
mean love I was confused by that
I'm not actually really sure that it's
just offline shots yes it's a it's a
Twitter bot that somebody set up
to basically just post what he says in
his chat when he's not live okay so
there's like a chat room when he's not
live yeah on Twitch even when you're not
live on your channel there you can still
be in the chat people are saying lqc I
like that
lqc baby remember when I said end times
yeah I was talking a train on Discord so
again they're colluding
behind the scenes to try to change the
subject in a super bad faith way
I was just on a call with train they're
loving it right they're loving it how
serious can they be taking these
allegations if they're pay pay laughing
on Discord together
imagine still defending cover-ups of
crimes that never happen
unless you can show that happening that
clip does not show that happening at all
finally finally hahaha
also they keep talking about how they're
such advocates for the victims he
literally titled the stream drama end
times season finale Extended Cut
directors cut premium version Double
Down double double Platinum rated IMDb
World rinners wow this is not a guy this
is a man who is treating it like a
circus
and by the way he did have the most
views on Twitch he had like 200 000
viewers so this was a circus that him
and his friend train created
they greatly benefited from it
and somehow
um Hassan's the bad guy for not reacting
uh
hard enough hard enough yeah well I
don't know what he expected he's like oh
my God
[ __ ] you [ __ ] moving on
okay and so uh on top of oh now now here
we go now we get in some good [ __ ]
remember how I said train wreck's the
biggest piece of [ __ ] scumbag check this
[ __ ] [ __ ] out
you know we were talking just on
Wednesday
how like it just doesn't make sense that
twitch isn't Banning gambling and Dan
said something about like are they being
paid off you know and I was like it just
seems so outlandish I mean I was only
half serious I was more just making the
point that like the longer this goes on
it's hard like conspiracy theories like
that are going to start coming out
because there is no logical explanation
for why they haven't acted
yeah so Austin Ox is actually Hassan's
uh editor shout out
pulled a clip
of train wreck playing on stake
talking to Twitch employees in his chat
and sending them 50
000
just because just to butter the beak bro
train wreck
this is [ __ ] nuts this blew my ass
open watch this
I think we're good let's get back to
this and let's wrap it up and then I'll
just gamble some more because I'm a
degenerate
getting that third one Joe I got 250
still on a trip
don't worry about it baby
I'll take care of YouTuber orange for a
minute I got you
for Pega fish are you kidding me bro
realm is that you on two staff accounts
bro the bigger fish comes in I give them
50k at least you can see he clicks
his profile here
Pepe Go Fish video platform developer at
twitch
he's an employee
also employees get a special like icon
right love so yeah so he sees them in
chat which is interesting because it's
like Rife for corruption but here uh
right in front of your eyes this is how
confident he is this comes in I give him
50k leaves you can even stay for [ __ ]
five more minutes
Jesus Christ
oh he said no one's ever sent him
anything like in the uh oh oh no shots
I love that
no one has ever sent me anything before
oh rellum that's so [ __ ] cute bro I
[ __ ] with that
for real that's low that's real [ __ ]
that I love that bro
no one has ever said anything before
that that is the sweetest most sad thing
ever isn't it this whole conversation is
mind-bending to me yeah nobody's ever
sent me 50K before just like that either
is that sweet and sad what the [ __ ] are
you talking about you really trying to
turn this into some heartwarming story
about corruption you just said fifty
thousand dollars like nothing at all to
a twitch and [ __ ] employee dude can
y'all believe this [ __ ] people are
saying audio
because of the music that was playing in
the background I think it's okay I think
it'll be all right it was really yeah it
was just kind of background [ __ ] can you
guys believe this this is so corrupt
and right on display man I'm telling you
this guy's absolute scum he is really
[ __ ] up that is so sweet bro that's
just beautiful man nobody's ever given
you 50k before for nothing
[ __ ] dude
50 yeah
that's really sweet and sad it's so sad
bro it's so sad
yeah really sad I feel so bad for this
program developer at twitch who probably
makes like 200 000 a year nobody's ever
given me anything before
really [ __ ]
he's not like a hustler cause I'm gonna
send him some more yo take 30. look then
you can see who goes through his crypto
wallet sends him another fifteen
thousand
that's by the way in sight and balance
which is pretty funny too
wait what does that mean it's stake
balance oh he's sending him steak money
or maybe he's withdrawing Maybe I'm
Wrong it says withdraw I mean here it
says withdraw okay so oh yeah he's
sending out of his stake wallet to this
Bitcoin address fifteen thousand dollars
in Bitcoin all right
yes dude
yes this is totally [ __ ] legit
can you imagine man this is nuts this is
nuts
any YouTube employees in the chat I
ain't giving you [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you
done for me lately
you got to do a lot more for me if you
want my cheddar
yeah this is just a straight up bribe
Kickback corruption it's just insane
pick 30 000 altogether
I sent you two fifteen thousand two
fifteen thousands baby that's 30 G's
realm do whatever you want with that you
know what I'm saying if you want to walk
into your the office and tell your boss
to suck your young and [ __ ] off the time
just kidding don't do that don't do that
yeah he gets this God complex too I've
noticed
the way he just hands out money to
people because again
steak is paying him like five million
dollars a month I mean you know
it's all ill-gotten money it's blood
Money
so there's that that one really blew my
ass off and then I think shortly after
that came to light twitch finally and
this is all happening at the same time
on the same day within like a three hour
window
uh finally bands
gambling on Twitch
this happened finally live when everyone
was talking about it and again I truly
think that it was that clip of train
bribing twitch employees that scared
them [ __ ] silly
uh you know because then all of a sudden
they're culpable right it's like okay
let me look a little bit more into this
like y'all are getting paid for this
okay interesting tell me more
so here they said gambling content on
Twitch has been a big topic of
discussion today we update our plans uh
while we prohibit sharing links and
referral codes to sites yo what
they prohibited that because train was
acting like he was a good guy for not
showing his referral code on screen
anyway they say October 18th we are
prohibiting gambling sites that include
slots roulettes dice games that aren't
licensed in the either the United States
or other jurisdictions that provide
sufficient consumer protection
these sites will include steak.com roll
bet dual bet rhubat.com
we may identify more as they go forward
we will continue to allow websites to
focus on sporting bet sports betting uh
fantasy sports and poker
so I'm correct me if I'm wrong but does
this include shacks and Curacao
is that that's not legit huh apparently
not apparently not because they said
they said either the United States or
other jurisdictions that provide a
sufficient consumer protection so that
doesn't include a shack and Carousel so
what what which which thing do you think
got them to finally move on this was it
you think it was trained it was train
bribing a clip of train paying off
twitch employees so you think it was
that without a doubt okay it happened
right out without a doubt because it but
all I mean all this happened within a
very short period of time there was also
the guy who scammed a bunch of viewers
that was already old news bro I mean
like two days ago they did this right
during the controversy right the thing
is when there's I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just saying that there are a
few things that it could have been dude
twitch it could be [ __ ] if
investigators find out that their
employees are getting paid off
by the way this is happening on stream
right it's happening off stream this is
like the tip of the iceberg he's paying
twitch employees
that's it yeah dude that's a bad bad
look for twitch
um
yeah so here by the way a bad news for
steak
Drake is really out of a big sponsorship
too man steak Hut replacement proposal
now this is so sad this is their Hut and
carousel
they're going out of business so I think
they're selling a water cooler
and uh one PC from 1997.
and the fax machine if anybody's looking
for uh
also I heard that uh come October
they're going to be actually selling
Halloween supplies a seasonal
a seasonal shopping experience
then come spring Shake Shack obviously
is making moves taking over so uh
residents of Curacao have that to look
forward to that's good
and finally just burning it down for uh
insurance fraud yeah just just burning
it down after that so it's worth more
burn than sitting there right so burn so
um
uh moving it to Ground Zero uh to
remembrance of national tragedy turn it
into a gambling addiction Rehabilitation
Center yeah I like just burn it
collect the uh the insurance on that
there are guys at stake you know
I have all my favorite moments by the
way of people finding out that uh
gambling was banned and all the coping
and seething that happens afterwards
train wreck actually tweeted this
today
at 12 he said
the Inc oh this two hours ago the
inconsistency not to ban sports betting
is corruption [ __ ] aren't you the one
paying off twitch employees shut the
[ __ ] up about corruption
such a liar dude this guy's the worst
considering the fact that you have your
hands in 13 billion NFL deal cookie jar
and the fact that you virtue signal
streamers act like you care about
gambling are silent oh my God Market
more prevalent they literally said
if you are working with the U.S casino
that can prove that they have sufficient
consumer protection then you can work
with them dude you're talking about like
massive
businesses located in the United States
it's not the same [ __ ] you're working
with the offshore crypto casinos shady
as [ __ ]
stop everything you do is bad faith
right
I mean I think that they should ban the
sports betting too frankly I don't
disagree with them on that but he's like
yeah no I agree ban all the gambling
yeah I mean it's it's a website for for
babies it's twitch you don't need to
have gambling on it do they have a
partnership with NFL I didn't know that
so Amazon does is what he's oh so
and and yeah oh because they just
sponsor them no the NFL is now
broadcasting games on on Prime
how does that
it's because it's all one big company
he's just saying but how does them
working with the NFL have to do with
sports betting because the NFL is
heavily involved in all that sports
betting stuff yeah so use that twitch
that's got nothing to do with twitch
he's saying they didn't ban the sports
betting because the parent company is
working closely with the NFL which
explicitly endorses dude this man tied
himself up into a pretzel trying to be
like you need to ban every form of
gambling in the whole world before you
talk about me playing an unregulated
offshore crypto casinos like I mean it's
true that they're not comparable I I
personally think that they shouldn't
allow either but you're right I mean
there are degrees of this and the
offshore crypto casinos is definitely
not is by far the worst as like
DraftKings or something like that and
train wreck and xqc their whole debate
has been reliant on bad faith arguments
and just another bad faith argument and
logical fallacy is that all forms of
gambling are equally bad when everybody
knows that steak.com located in a Shack
in carousel now that it forces you to
play with untraceable [ __ ] crypto is
a billion times worse than draftking
which is a us-based company well
regulated with oversight that pays taxes
and [ __ ]
working with the NFL like shut the [ __ ]
up idiot [ __ ]
I despise him he is such something idiot
he really is such a scumbag uh he
continues on
also I I just need to point out both him
and xuc I remember even last year he was
when he got into the argument on a call
with you yeah
um his favorite go-to thing is is virtue
signal he hates virtue signaling yeah he
says that a lot and and you hear it a
lot from from people like him that you
know nobody nobody actually cares about
these things they're just virtue
signaling I just find it a little ironic
that as we were just talking about the
whole
throwing out this girl's
essay allegations as a way to deflect
and pretending like he cares about that
that
is the most textbook definition of
virtue signaling you could possibly come
up with like there there is no clear
example of virtue signaling he does not
care that this girl got assaulted he
only cared because he was able to
benefit the weaponize it he's greatly
benefiting that her story hex book dude
he literally benefited so much from her
story yes
like
doesn't that make anyone else
uncomfortable that he benefited from
this story like let's just be let's just
say that as it is he used it in a way
and said it even xqc said it to benefit
them
and then he's got the balls to go and
accuse Pokemon and Hassan of not
reacting hard enough I'm sorry I just
got I have no respect for this man he's
ultimate scum yeah
uh he keeps going he said
Banning other forms of gambling while
keeping the most prevalent form of it
gets them paid as a [ __ ] joke and a
mistake instead they should have banned
the people who do it wrong and in
predatory non-transparent fashion okay
good so ban you
actually that's kind of what they did
they banned all the unregulated offshore
crypto casinos that's literally what
they did yeah and I mean if he wants to
make the argument that they should ban
all the other stuff too
you had that movement I'm right behind
you buddy right yeah or maybe he's just
virtue signaling that he cares when he
doesn't
yo train wreck let's lead the revolution
baby no gambling
B you can be my leader
but yeah like you said I mean there is
definitely a difference between
DraftKings and mistake yeah and then and
again it's just it's a bad faith to even
compare them it's like there are levels
to everything
Hassan is debating xqc when it comes
down and this is probably the most
priceless reaction xqc who is a giant
stooge piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] cuck to
gambling who literally said they
weaponized the news to benefit
themselves watch this in a policy update
on October 18th I'm doing a mogul mail
right now boys
the plan is simple all right I don't do
that yeah so we'll be making a policy
update on October 18th the private
streaming of gambling sites that include
slots roulette or dice games that aren't
licensed either in the US or other
jurisdictions that provide sufficient
consumer protection these sites will
include steak.com rollbit.com dual
bits.com and ruby.com however we may
identify others as we move forward
rip Rip Van Elk boys it's not we could
actually have send moments
you guys you guys thought that was
against it the whole time right this
[ __ ] has the balls to say and
and he was the guy who was just
screaming about Hassan saying he
backpedaled when when he thought public
opinion would back him up this [ __ ]
hypocrite literally just said you guys
know I was against this the whole time
what
uh Ludwig does a good job of dunking on
him in the aftermath of that
my numbingly pathetic statement yeah I
know you're against it but then you just
still do it greedily but I I knew that
you were morally against it but I think
it's funny to be morally against it and
still do it I think it's hilarious that
you did a scope
you're also tweeting out to pay people
back I think it's it's funny and ironic
but you know what about that scary way
that
about paying everybody back who got
scammed you did a slot spinning one 1.5
you're doing it right now you son of a
[ __ ] all right you you get you keep
these [ __ ] 28 days left you maximize
baby then you're done for 28 days oh my
[ __ ] Lord yeah I mean these guys are
just Shameless and somehow they actually
convince people to support them which is
really shocking because like I said he
actually had them on the back pedal
apologizing and it was just really
making me my head spin there's one more
Karina
who is which people have literal gaming
addiction uh working with steak because
of why not she's you know no twitch
people have literal gaming addictions
that's what I said last night people
literally are to sitting on their
computer dude people have [ __ ] people
tick tock addictions people literally
sit on their computer all [ __ ] day
long
and [ __ ] dude I mean you can be
addicted to [ __ ] anything it's just
whatever
that's her response the what aboutism is
just incredible I mean you guys
are just so desperate to defend the bag
that you're you're from you're defending
[ __ ] scumbag criminal stake I mean
these guys are the worst or the worst
uh so
um
here's train wreck uh leaving chat
it's like [ __ ] up that you did this
it's wrong that you did this something
that you also personally recognize
I literally used that term on purpose
just like I also accounted for uh for
for additional underlying uh uh reasons
as to why you may or may not be going
when I said I'm sure there's more to it
and I didn't even [ __ ] know that
there was more to it at the time I just
suspected it and the reason why is this
right before the reason why the news
breaks or is this a good time stamp
I don't know I'm not sure I didn't
timestamp all right well anyway that's
pretty much it
um you know the whole thing was just so
gross it made me so sick
you know in short it's good that the
essay allegations came forward
I'm glad that that the girl that
happened to was able to get some like
relief enclosure I'm also glad that that
disgusting freak slick who has a history
of of doing this stuff
is known to be that
I think it's also separately disgusting
how xqc and train wreck manage
themselves during all this honestly
honestly
unforget I mean just
irredeemably gross
and I think Hassan and Pokey were in the
right the whole time they did nothing
wrong and uh I'm just glad that twitch
band gambling finally so
sucks to be any of these [ __ ] idiots
whose tit is off and I just can't wait
for train wreck by the way he goes I do
this for Love of the Game if I wasn't
being paid I'd be doing this every day
I'm down millions and millions of
millions of dollars I can't wait for
train wreck to keep playing stake like
he says he will after the ban is up so
if if what train wreck said is true he's
going to go broke in a couple months
because this he does it for Love of the
Game and it doesn't matter that they're
paying him so we gotta check with
Trainwreck to make sure he's still
gambling on stake after they stop paying
it
and you think um he'll just switch to
sports betting or something I mean I
guess nobody's gonna watch that well I
would say who's watching this [ __ ]
slot machines but it's sports that's
active it's action there's spins there's
anticipation sports betting you got to
watch a whole game poker is super slow
paced I don't I don't know I find poker
I actually like watching poker I find it
I do too but I don't think trainwreck's
a good enough player to make it
interesting yeah I don't know I don't
know about like a back rat or like some
other like James Bond [ __ ] yeah like
yeah well the gravy train just arrived
so um let me just thank our sponsors
real fast and we'll bring uh we can
we'll bring Mr gravy on okay
um
let me think our sponsors real fast
gamer sup Nation rise the [ __ ] up Gamer
sucks up
today I'm drinking
Citrus lemonade
so good it's so energizing
I love gamer sub
gamer Subs the new partner of the
channel we love them gave over 10 000 of
you whoa 10 000 people got a free uh
trial that's awesome gamersup offers the
healthiest and best tasting alternative
to Inner drinks and soda sugar sucks
it's terrible for you actually just
learned that it can cause depression too
negative effects should include weight
gain increased risk of heart disease
acne enjoy getting an energized boost in
your day by simply throwing two scoops
of the shake into your Shaker Scupper
shaker cup or water bottle
it's that simple you remember uh
washboard abs uh
psychiatrist that we had on them you
could get washboard abs just like that
if you drink gamer stuff yeah
take a couple Scoops out
oh it's a tiny scoop look at that
because you don't have to think about it
two of these yep and you're energized
and tastes great I love it man I I love
it
been seeing a lot of feedback from the
fupa Troopers that they did the offer
for the free samples isn't that crazy
that they that that was such a good idea
oh not really quick too I've been seeing
a ton of people say they just got them
like a couple days later and that
they're loving it so
tastes great
it's so much better than drinking a
sugary drink and it's honestly way
cheaper too 35 cents per serving
a lot of people use this product you
know to get a healthier Edge to cut out
the sugar it's got zero sugar zero
calories 100 milligrams of organic
caffeine
it even has a caffeine free option if
that's what you're looking for
uh we gave it a bunch of free samples
last time so if you enjoyed them and are
looking to grab your first tub shake or
any other cool stuff use the code H3
gives you free shipping to anywhere in
the world on all orders over 30 bucks
for the next 72 hours after after 72
hours the code will still give a 10
discount in case you grab some later so
code H3
free shipping anywhere in the world
over 30 bucks fart is their favorite I
haven't tried I gotta try block
name is on the name did put me off a
little bit but apparently it's very good
somebody else just said Glock gamer fart
is so good if you want to see an H3
Shaker or flavor in the future go
support and don't forget to use the code
H3 guys the link in the description
takes you right to the website hey guys
sorry I'm I'm sorry I'm uh slacking I'm
almost done
thank you guys thank you bro nice seeing
you
uh if you want to yeah please use
there's a link in description guys go to
the website use the code we love you
gamer sub Nation forever
um yes indeed next up hellofresh
you guys know fupa Troopers live for
hellofresh
farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipe delivered right to your
doorstep skip trips to the grocery store
count on Ella fresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it's America's number one meal kit for
pizza's sake you don't have to think
about it dude
they send you a you know a box of the
most beautiful lovely food to cook
yourself
they tell you how to do it it's
delicious it's more affordable
it's a no-brainer you don't have to
think about it dude you don't even have
to think about it dude uh fubotroopers
love hellofresh especially a b right
uh special EAB although he just uh
oh there he is come on in I I I
absolutely love it we need a new dish
from you bro you need to do some oh oh
what's up what's up wait a minute what's
this tell me more about this dish I've
actually I've been actually working on
something oh okay that's exciting
Chef a b
abh3
uh if you're looking for more ways to
save money hellofresh is 25 less
expensive than takeout and it's even
cheaper than grocery store shopping
because you don't have all that waste
hellofresh Works around your schedule
plans are flexible and you can change
your meal preference update your
delivery day and even change your
address
with just a few Taps of the hellofresh
app
every time a hell of fresh dinner comes
it's a good night you know you're
getting a delicious a healthy meal a
well-balanced meal and uh it's fresh I
mean I don't know what to say it's a
no-brainer you know what they uh they
sent to me last week was this
I don't want to call it Pizza it was
like a pita bread pizza kind of thing
yeah I think it was a flat bread flat
bread there you go but it just came
packaged it was like the easiest thing
ever it's all like pre-made you don't
even stick it out of the package threw
it in the oven for about 30 minutes and
damn that [ __ ] was [ __ ] of course it's
good oh we have a new offer some of you
guys are gonna love this hellofresh.com
65h3 use the code 65h3 and get 65 off
plus free shipping wow that's what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about wow unbelievable
and that's why my friends is America's
number one meal kit guys hellofresh.com
865 H3 use code 65 HD for 65 off plus
free shipping thank you thank you let's
bring the gravy train up
young gravy is here at long glass what's
up
he's coming
he's here he is uh
join me you're right here next to me bud
oh we have hey man how are you
oh thank you what's this
oh thanks bro who are you
tip love that DJ and bestie and all that
DJ bestie Ted you love that what's this
nice to meet you man pleasure nice to
see you here
last time and I was late this time no
[ __ ] respect I'm sorry bro ah dude
it's all good man I'm you still do the
same thing good oh I like the background
yeah so uh yeah it's a springtime
background so um what do we got here you
bring me a present do you need can we
get some water for gravy are we turning
up on on
your stimulants right now you want some
G gamer stuff yeah so get him to get him
the guacamole can I get some guacamole
for our gamer shop hell yeah man yeah I
love this [ __ ] I did do uh an app for G
fuel lately oh no we don't talk about
that we don't okay I figured yeah you
put that word out [ __ ] G fuel bro
yo you work with G4 that's cool it's all
good they got bad they're more they're
mortal uh enemies Gamers all right let's
see what you get me Ethan and Ela thanks
for having us love you all here's a
little gift for you from tip
for him we love y'all baby
that's from gravy
I uh we're he's a huge fan my man dude
tip come here Tim come here dog come on
dude I got you I found these them around
my house so you have some extra Vapes
from Vapes that I found around the house
so I don't want to hit it at all but I'm
gonna try to hit the scope though thanks
dude not a huge vague guy but I'm just
gonna try to hit it Tim come here
oh yeah tips are real fast couple bell
peppers that's the real one too yeah do
you have any idea what that means yeah I
didn't know that part yeah okay let's
take a bite thanks bro
yeah yeah we can share something yeah
that's super sweet should we do it yeah
yeah all right there we go yeah no no
you're gonna deal with that yeah yeah
all right Cheers Cheers oh you guys want
to get intimate with this that's all
three at the same time we all made it in
it
that was the [ __ ] up never tasted so
good okay
sweet huh
you ever do that it's cracking through a
bell pepper like that absolutely
not with a tomato but thank you bro
yeah I don't want this at all but I
thought it at my house and there it is
I'm gonna I was gonna try to force
myself to rip the Vape today are you uh
are you uh a smoker
I I had a face cigarettes yep so it's
not are you like dependent on that like
usually you'd be smoking or something or
is that that gets you through no I have
I have like a two-month phase when I
went to Europe and everyone was doing it
and I wanted to fit in and yeah yeah
yeah I mean I took me a little like
another couple weeks after to get off of
it but now I'm not really a big city
okay okay yeah that happened to me when
I was in Israel everyone there like
just chain smokes bro so they got me I
literally found me sitting at my house
and I was like you know let's Vape up
dude yo bro that watch is insane exactly
I got your take on this watch that thing
is nice you gotta datejust right gravy
uh yeah datejust Oyster Perpetual I
don't know that thing I don't know the
fancy details but it's um it's beautiful
man the mother of pearl thank you very
beautiful what do you think exactly
impressed a fairy yeah what's the wreath
what's the MSRP on that like 10 000
that's not not like oh insane rolly but
it's a little song that's how much yours
cost Zach his looks more beautiful than
yours what year is yours it's like 90s
80s
I don't know I brought I brought it
fresh from the from the icebox brand new
baby so I mean I mean I've been wearing
this for four years haven't even
switched it up every day of my life is
on my wrist beautiful years now you
think wearing a Rolex does something for
you when you roll around you think that
people notice you roll around uh I've
always wondered there are there are like
the you know guys who will be super into
watches and start like naming off facts
and everything and I don't know I don't
really know you don't follow I like the
color of it it's beautiful I like it and
it adds a little something and I don't
know my dad dad Swiss and I wanted to
wrap something on me so beautiful baby
well um
oh yeah try that I've been wondering
what that tastes like it is green people
have been saying it's the best flavor so
hit that up
tastes like Baja Blast kind of oh [ __ ]
that's a good review I love bottom
breath kind of like Riptide rough
Gatorade as well
so um
I wanted to ask you well first of all I
want to ask you a few things I know that
you're you're the MILF hunting thing is
is serious for you when's the first time
that you had sex with a or
you've slept with many MILFs I
understand you're a bit of a MILF Slayer
I mean I'm you know a
relative relatively decent amount yeah
insane you know I'm not I'm not insane
I'm not going Gene Simmons mode but uh
a handful and I I think the first time
was was in high school late late high
school was it a friend's mom not a
friend's mom so who was she no one I
wouldn't do that I was a woman that
sold me drugs yo did she have kids did
it have kids did her kids no that's what
a MILF that's like kind of well I know
but that's another question I want to
ask you as our now resident MILF expert
do they have to have kids
well you see there's MILF and cougar and
and I think they kind of just get you
know combined sometimes you know I I
believe that uh
if you have a
a pet cat and you take really good care
of it as your child you could be a MILF
you have a pet cat
because it's an old [ __ ]
just you know it's a child a child yeah
okay all right I see as long as they
have some kind of type of something they
care about under there yeah okay indeed
yeah so you first had sex with the MILF
in high school and and did that set on
your lifelong passion for slaying it was
it was you know it was a little bit
influential and I think it it
played a part in
my lyrical content but I just you know
once I started rapping and and you know
creating a brand I I figured you know
this MILF thing is is to vibe I'm into
it other people are into it no one's
talking about it let's get it out there
oh you know what that's so true because
if you look at the PornHub stats I think
and you guys can maybe fact check this
the number one category was MILF dude
it's got to be step sibling no I think
it's milk it's milk or a MILF is at
least like one or two I want to think
that I maybe help contribute to that a
little bit so that 2021 MILF was number
four oh it's number four okay but it's
mil is it number one in some countries
or States I believe it is here I'll keep
looking now but that surprised me
because it's like you said nobody talks
about the MILF phenomenon until now
until now now you're you're the uh
spokesperson yeah man you're bringing it
to the Forefront would you date a girl
your age oh yeah I have yeah you would
have absolutely yeah it's not it's not
strictly MILFs and I think people
believed that and then had a little
Scandal go on uh with a sex tape that
got leaked online what you had a sex
tape yeah it's it's nothing too crazy
what you guys didn't mention the sex
tape
tell me about it from the internet oh
she's seen it I saw it in your eyes uh
it's uh it's a wholesome little
wholesome little uh video it's it's you
know as sex tapes goes about as
wholesome and mellow do you see can you
see dick in it barely yeah a little dick
drunk a little trunk little trunk okay
it's a base
um but it was uh and what is your what
is your dick doing in the shop having
sex okay it's going in penetrating yeah
and then so the the my point was is that
it's clear in the video that the woman's
not a MILF oh that phone just stream
that video blew up and everyone was like
bro what is he doing oh my God and um
the video was kind of funny I'd say
watch it afterwards I mean I like flip
the camera around and I like smile I can
pull it up you guys want to send me I
won't I won't watch it on if that's not
uncomfortable for you but I'll watch I'm
watching it but it I mean I won't put it
on the screen yeah just watch it so I
can tell the people what I'm seeing go
ahead yeah
so how did the video leap okay I I got
hacked by you guys if anyone's Gonna
Know You guys probably know you know
chuckling Squad nah nah I don't know who
they target them but it's it's like a
group of Hackers from
I don't know where but they they've
gotten like a lot of other
celebrities in the past and basically
their whole plan is just hack someone's
account tweet the n-word you know just
just to piss people off yeah [ __ ] I've
seen that that's such a crazy game plan
that's like how they got they got James
Charles and then everybody thought that
the the
they were actually really
right I remember he tweeted some crazy
ideas yeah
I think some people do still think it's
real actually so did they do that to you
did they oh they tried but I had a I had
a good hacker friend myself who was
hacking them back at the same time so I
mean there was like a three hour period
where they had my they did a Sim swap
Sim swap someone tried that to me once
yep yeah Sim Swap and then they got my
number and they got into all these
accounts and I was going off like a new
I had two phones at the time luckily and
I was like trying to handle everything
and they didn't get any like really
offensive tweets out there there was one
tweet where like some fan asked for like
free passes and they just quoted and
they said hell no he's like man like
just being a dick people thought it was
funny but I was like no that's that's
not me uh and and they had access to my
iCloud and and they waited this long but
they had that video and dropped it wow
like two years later so you by the way
the Sim swap thing is so scary that was
like so close bro I was so close to like
losing my YouTube channel you don't put
your number into anything anymore like
like tooth Factor all that stuff yeah I
had to go get crazy high security at ATT
I like I found a guy who worked there
was a fan and he gave me like that's
what I'd like to an account that has
like three businesses and then they're
all named random things and they have
addresses and it's not traceable yeah
totally because basically how it works
is they'll these guys it's called social
engineering right they'll call the phone
company
and they'll just keep calling until they
find someone dumb enough
to believe that they work for the phone
company and then you say oh I need a new
SIM card issued for this person and then
they send a new SIM card and then
basically they can get all your
two-steps factors yeah yeah
that's scary well I'm glad it was just a
little bit of a trunk there yeah I mean
I mean it was there was a the first
moment and then two years later they
came back with the sex tape drop which
you know was pretty lame and I you know
scarred some of the younger fans
probably and felt really bad for the
girl who's in the video and everything
but uh
I think it's all good now it's pretty
much scraped but if you follow me I
didn't know that oh it's great that's
how we didn't find it oh we found it oh
we found it okay we found it yeah it's
uh apparently just a go to
gravysdick.com and if you want to yeah
you know what go ahead it's quick and do
you want me to watch this sure yeah yeah
I do want to see a reaction all right so
here is um going to watch uh young
gravy's sex tape here oh my God that's
the face
you're having a fun time man all right
so here it is okay
uh girl uh and what would be referred to
colloquial as a doggy style
you're having a really good time you
guys seem to be really
lots of gusts though man
[Music]
yeah I don't like that laugh combined
with my sex tape I think um see it's
it's not bad because audio it's like I'm
smiling and I like I address myself I'm
like hey buddy and then I kind of I say
I talk about having a leg cramp it's
kind of like oh they're just having fun
how did you what was it's like you were
posting a it's almost like you filmed it
like a tick thought
I guess so I literally was filming I was
like no I'm done with this and I threw
the phone down and it landed facing me
and I said let's go all right I'm
smiling myself and I never thought I'd
go anywhere it was just a one-time thing
but the girl who's in it was she she's
cool I mean that yeah that sucks that
she got roped into it because those yeah
there were no issues that came out of it
yeah that's good we handled it but she
looks like she's having everyone's
having a good time here so yeah yeah
yeah very nice well shout out young
gravy
just saw your dick a little bit that's
okay you want me to show you mine I
would love that okay yeah after the show
later I'll whip it up for you thanks man
yeah of course anything man I feel like
we're already uh dogs after that
yeah we are we met about eight minutes
ago and you saw my opinion already
talked yeah exactly
um I want to talk to you a little bit
about your come up
um you've been how long you been making
music
six years okay it's about six years now
I feel like that's a pretty good time
frame yeah to be like discovered I I
think there was about two years of me
riding really hard on Soundcloud and I I
at first I didn't show my face anywhere
because I had a job that I wanted to get
like like a job that was locked in for
after college I was going to University
of Wisconsin
and I had a job locked in I didn't want
to lose that so I wasn't showing my face
I don't want my boss to hear anything
but I also kind of thought it was a cool
little stick to like hide my face and
like all my art was just pin up girls
and like vintage stuff uh so that was
like two years worth of like slightly
growing to the point where I was like
okay like this is kind of serious I
could drop a video I dropped a video
where I revealed my face and it blew up
a lot of it was just everyone commenting
oh my God I thought he was black and and
interesting because my voice about voice
is low
um and then let me think that would have
been in 2019 and no 2018 went on tour
right after I graduated college early
we're on tour 10 days later and ever
since then it's been damn engraving man
that is a gravy train bro that's cool
um what was the what what did you study
what was the job you were looking to get
well I studied marketing and finance
yeah I ended up dropping Finance for the
early graduation and I worked at a
startup accelerator it's kind of like a
record label for for Tech so like
someone comes up with like uh a cool new
technology
a new sleep apnea machine or something
but they're a PhD student so they're
kind of nerdy you don't really know how
to make something sexy so then I was the
guy that would come in and make it sexy
damn brand it and teach them how to talk
to an audience you feel like that skill
you were able to apply to like your own
brand yeah absolutely yeah that was
that's like my bread and butter that's
so interesting yeah what are some things
that you knew going into this where
you're like I need to Market myself good
here's some things I know I need to do
just be different be unique
um
have something recognizable that is your
thing that no one else has and for me
now there's like you know the Vintage
sort of
art work the MILF thing obviously is one
of the main ones love them
um I have a lot of samples in my music
that other people aren't using I got
this this very particular one from a
Dennis Edwards song where goes it's in
every single song of mine people don't
miss that and yeah man just making
yourself different Stand Out interesting
every time you use that short sample do
you have to pay no we we
um there was close to being an issue but
I actually just recreated something very
similar to it oh yeah yeah I have to do
a lot of stuff like that say the sample
clearance processes are not fun so a lot
of stuff yeah that's one of my questions
I want to ask you I noticed that the
sampling is super heavy I mean you're
you're really your big hit right now is
the uh yeah Betty what you sample the uh
Rick Roll
so is that a really what's that process
like the sample that song basically we
we have a few good friends that are
really good uh instrument players and
recreating anything or original
compositions too but we we recreated the
original song what completely you didn't
even license it so we didn't say well we
had the the
on the publishing side it's confusing
but basically the people who wrote the
song since we use the same chords and
the same lyrics and everything they have
to clear it but since we didn't use the
actual audio from the song
There's a whole step we stepped or step
we skipped wow yeah and um
Rick Astley wasn't actually involved
because he didn't write it so
um
yeah basically he's down with the song
though I mean like he's a fan but but
there's three other riders that had had
to approve it and I had to change all
the lyrics because it was a lot dirtier
and then I had to make it cleaner damn
man I did that's that's so unexpected so
they are getting a little bit on the
back side
but but not that much because you you
it's your music on the publishing side
which would be like radio play or if it
gets put in a movie or something okay
they're making a bag for sure they own a
good percentage of it but anything else
like streams and that's all you stuff
it's your boy wow that's so cool yeah it
works out well and you also did uh there
was one you did uh Mr Clean yeah Mr
Sandman I know I love this bro uh Mr
Clean same thing was one of many songs
that I I put out way early on didn't
know I didn't even have a lawyer I
didn't know how to clear a sample so I
put them out without clearing it yeah
and then with those songs a lot of times
no one notices and then eventually they
come back uh when the song's big and
sometimes they're cool about it
sometimes they're dicks yeah I would
imagine they're always dead they're
surprisingly like especially the song's
doing really well and they get to meet
me then they're pretty cool but like
George Michael's estate for example I
had I had a pretty big settlement
sampled Careless Whisper and that one is
just I have to pitch I really big check
out to him like the Monday so yeah
sometimes they don't love it
are you what was the result of the Mr
Sandman one that one was like they that
I took a while I'm gonna find two I
think it was already like gold or
platinum and they finally came because
because that's the original songs made
in the 50s or yeah I think mid 50s 1954.
yeah oh wow that's my guy's cute so uh
they finally found it the the surviving
members of or the not the surviving
members I guess the estate that's around
and they they were cool with it whoever
whoever checked it out was fans and then
give them a percentage that's so nice
yeah when you give them a percent what
kind of percent are we talking about
it's not like that I mean that dude like
literally that song is purely a sample
with some drums on it so that one like
fair enough I think we gave him
eighty percent damn that's a tough
business boy but I mean I was like dude
I but it is their song right yeah that's
what I did yeah do you have to pay him
back though for like the years you you
had it going and didn't the parents yeah
follow up to them yeah and like in my
lawyer negotiating and all that stuff
yeah [ __ ] that's confusing man do you
feel like you lose out on a lot of
revenue from all from sampling all this
[ __ ] well my old songs I sampled a lot
now I just make my own sandwich about it
yeah I usually recreate stuff
um original that's so cool I didn't even
know you could do that yeah man not a
lot of people do it people sleep on it
there it is young gravy there you have
it remixing it
uh may I call you Mr gravy okay all
right cool just making sure I want to be
uh respectful at all time yeah man so um
I wanted to show you a couple things
here
um
I wanted to get your take on a few
things here all righty um you know who
you're on Tick Tock a lot you're very
popular in Tick Tock I don't look at it
but I post on it okay so so did you do
you know about Howie Mandel's tick tock
I do I do because because uh he asked me
to be on a podcast oh he asked dude did
you blow him up no I mean I I've sent I
sent it on to my man how many watches
that [ __ ] and then right after that
right afterwards they came back uh or
someone came back like did you see that
he just posted posted a butthole on his
Tick Tock did you see the original I
didn't see it no no it's not just a
button yeah so let me show you uh the
clip we're gonna watch it now all right
yeah this is my favorite thing and I
like just to keep the dream alive okay
with Howie Mandel now when someone told
you uh he posted a butthole you can see
right here uh is this what did what you
imagined they meant uh put this audio
please Zach
yeah it's up does somebody know is this
covid related and if it is what do we do
about it
ow when my friend Neil bent over this
house would you describe that as a
butthole or does somebody know is this
coveted people at home and if it is
that's a prolapse yeah that's a fully
prolapse of course taking a poop it's
[ __ ] gnarly that's pretty brutal yeah
so shut up casually said yeah you know
let's do that
what do we do about it yeah so what do
we do about that and then also there's
one other thing I'd like to show is
there anything you want to say about how
he's uh prolapse or are we just gonna
move on how is prolapse
um
rate it maybe
interesting interesting choice man I
think he looked like he was just feeling
himself I think he didn't think it was
weird no he bro he was all about that
prolapse yeah he was he was feeling he
was trying to roast me or something and
the thing is how he saw PC his whole
image is so clean so he's like
this is just another day our prolapse
butthole is not PC
it's pretty some people consider it
pretty pretty uh graphic graphic can you
show up normal butthole on tick tock
probably not right I guess yeah yeah it
prolapses it's probably even one whole
different yeah or maybe it becomes
medical at that point I don't know okay
okay so like like you know so
guidelines correct I guess politically
correct it's like
fair enough it's a time you know it's an
interesting dialogue uh again also so
many years oh yeah you know boys are you
cool with them oh yeah yeah
you like them great guys uh Steve will
do it I'm a big fan of you know you
don't like them I listen I like Steve
will do it I wanted to show this
anecdote this is just something we show
our guests for fun okay uh so I just
want to get your reading I've met him
there they're really nice guys no I
agree yeah yeah it's a vibrant it's good
it's good I like them but I can see you
know you think I'm setting you up yeah
yeah you feel it coming but it's okay
I'm just gonna play this and uh you tell
me what you think in the meantime yeah
go for it you're gonna need it honestly
I miss my ex-girlfriend's dogs
I miss I swear I really miss that's dude
that's the thing oh dude when we broke
up we broke up for eight months what is
it how I started talking I started
messing Donald on Instagram I really
miss her dogs man yeah dogs are dope
Selena um our dog start is like is he's
recently he's been like you come home
and there's just come everywhere what
are you talking about put them over the
couches
and you see it you see the come I
usually come stains in his dick is like
all big and throbbing so like it sucks
but like
this is like kind of crazy I'm saying
this but one I'm the cool dad now okay
and I'm the favorite you're the favorite
of cool and two you can control where
the [ __ ] goes what are you talking about
how do you do this so I get IVs all the
time yeah yeah I know you know they wear
gloves yes so lately I've been just like
row so you just go you put on the glove
and he said Donald he's going on his
stomach or like on his stomach right
here or like you go cow style cow style
better for catching and then you go and
usually just play like uh like uh like I
like cartoon like Disney like family
friendly and [ __ ] uh and you just has
been uh I've been just like jerking off
Donnie jerking your dog off I swear
that's wait wait wait wait wait hold on
so you're telling me right now that
you've been jerking your dog off so he
doesn't go Dad
it might sound crazy but it's strictly
business
um okay
is where and kind of I've watched
something occupy myself and it's more of
just a it's more of a little workout but
the thing is like dude I'm the cool dad
because imagine if you couldn't jerk off
and like it's like what the [ __ ] do I do
he comes by like [ __ ] a pillow
you know that's his normal that's his
normal move do yeah but imagine imagine
you trying to come by like [ __ ] a
pillow like it's probably like hard yeah
it's probably not the best yeah but then
imagine you had someone to come in and
go help you out yeah and then honestly
that's [ __ ] that's dope of you bro
play reasons I gotta control where the
[ __ ] goes okay and I feel like he likes
me better and he likes me way better
than Selena now because I'm I'm the cool
dad dude I'll be honest I didn't see
this conversation going that way but I
was I kind of like it's crazy I kind of
respect it I guess so are you into dogs
or are you a dog person
more of a cat guy I don't drink up I'll
jerk mine off but yeah I started giving
our cat I live in a house but a few
people started giving her more catnip
and I'm the cool dad now I didn't you
didn't have to finger these lengths yeah
yeah you just the catnip that's what
usually people do just give them treats
yeah he goes on and you don't think that
was a bit bro no curious as a heart
attack that [ __ ] went on for 20 minutes
bro
he talked about it's not a long bit okay
no I'm telling you I haven't met him I
met everybody else so you know he's a
good guy though he just like he was like
just like and and then his dog would
agree I mean you could see you could
tell he had good intentions you know he
was just trying to look out for the dog
and the household that's a cool cool dad
yeah cool dad I bet
uh but there you go so your uh gravy is
a cat person you hear me here folks cat
guy yeah I know that people might not
like that man I'm sorry but I uh I just
at my house we have a really cute cat
and a baby Husky and the Husky is really
cute but she's really annoying and the
cat and I are just like hyped oh yeah
huskies are super high energy dog
fighting things and yeah like jumping
over tables it's still my hot dog and
things like that oh no we can't be we
can't do that man how was the Husky
husky now has got it uh I was older now
it's gotta be like four or five months
getting bigger oh my God she's just a
tiny a puppy it was a little little
[ __ ] but now now she's she's getting
up there damn
she's getting up there so is tip the one
taking care of the Husky how's that work
tip doesn't live at my house he comes up
the block but I got a a little sort of
like almost rapper emo rapper frat house
Vibe guys a bunch of us Studios and a
bunch of dudes staying there it's a good
time good time anyone else I would know
that's staying there
uh let me think Bryce Vine a little
Aaron used to live with us a little area
a little Aaron you learn and no I don't
uh yeah I think you might like a lion
you guys would get along it's uh oh here
he is cute oh yeah wow looking good
that's me and her when she's littler
oh she's a big girl
she's big now yeah huskies are huskies
are known to be like super pain in the
ass dogs because they have they have so
much energy yeah they have to have so
much stimulus or they'll just destroy
your house yeah yeah well wolves wolves
yeah
you know Oliver tree he's a piece of
[ __ ] just want to mention that too if
you know who he is his music sucks I did
uh I did Jess pod I thought you did had
Jeff on here yeah whittak yeah um I did
his podcast I think the first thing he
said at least one in the first few
minutes of interview is do you know how
every tree is a piece of [ __ ] well
that's interesting I mean he has that
effect on people he really sucks his
music was horrible too I really like him
over FaceTime I've never never met him
in person he's he's just trying to suck
up too because he knows you're on the
come up I didn't like the I didn't like
the original bulk up or the new hair is
a little better or what are the uh the
Kid Rock look what yeah what did he do
to you
he's a piece of [ __ ] I just won't get I
just wanted to tip you off give you a
heads up yeah he [ __ ] a 70 year old
I know that he was he was trying to like
Flex on me he hit me just for that
reason he's like man I know you've been
with women like around 50 but I just
wait who's what's the oldest you've
slept with I mean he was 49 but I was 24
so therefore 51 bigger age Gap you think
big what bigger age Gap well I mean she
stayed the same age and I said I mean
she grew and I grew so it's the same Gap
but now she's 51. indeed he went to 70.
you know I wanted to speaking of
Smashing MILFs
um
I see you put out a ranking of your top
five MILFs of all time right oh yeah
yeah so a few regards number one I was
asking this in every interview it's just
a classic like oh let's get gravy in an
interview and let's think of something
original to ask him so so well well well
this is a good one don't don't group Us
in yet okay you said Sophia vegara
obviously beautiful Sherry Nicole that's
Addison Ray's mom right you smashed that
foreign
[Music]
if you guys didn't sing if you didn't
have sex
oh [ __ ] I can't get the read
but you put a number two
yeah I think it's weird man we had a
good we had a good time
yeah how late you guys hang out was it
like a next morning thing or like a
she well she came to the VMAs with me is
my day yeah yeah and and she came out
the day before took on a nice dinner
date she ended up being such a
sweetheart so you guys go whose house
did you go back to us we used to have
the same Hotel same Hotel yeah different
rooms were they connected was there a
door connecting them
we had a uh great little hotel
experience we we did the VMAs the
following day and then just one more day
to chill a little bit man it's a good
time you know she's actually she's
actually pretty young what did she what
do we say she's like 42 42. I just
turned 43 on September 4th you know her
you're very familiar with her age I just
sang so you guys stayed at the same
Hotel did you guys have a nightcap after
the VMAs yeah it doesn't mean we had sex
man no I'm not hey what look I didn't
imply that I said nightcap what'd you
guys drink
was a Black Label Johnny Walker nice
drink
you drink it with ice or straight how
did she drink it I go I think we took
shots I think it was shots yeah oh y'all
definitely [ __ ] man do it take him
ratchet shots come on oh man I was just
celebrating man it was our first day I
didn't I'm gonna did my VMAs performance
I was hyped on it yeah it was good man
that was exciting it's exciting was
there any other homies there was it just
the two of you uh we had my I mean the
whole Squad was a big tip about a hotel
man big tip yeah was he in the room
though no
yeah tape comes everywhere yeah you
gotta have them everywhere no no no I'm
not pounding for tip there was no one
else in the room but you and Sherry
Addison Ray's mom
right you
you said at some point yeah we take
shots
never give you rest or no
but I pounded it
you did found it gravy got racks by the
way I just been uh
I've been so captivated by this story
because I don't know what's real and
what's fake and how much is stick or not
of the Addison Ray mom thing
uh but I'm starting to think you
actually did
yeah hang out intimately with her well
we'll see we've been flirting a little
bit on the internet and
I want to show a good time man she she
you know should be going through it and
and she's a single lady now and when I
set up the first date uh honestly my
first go-to was Martha Stewart because I
brought her as my date to other places
is she not too old she wasn't available
that day so so Sherry came out we met
and she was she was sweet she had to
meet my whole team and and uh we had a
great little
[Music]
quite recently
[Music]
yeah just show me you guys are texting
what do you want to say no I'm just
kidding
I know it's on your phone I just seen it
she lives in uh Louisiana I live here oh
she's so she's far away
you know I can't have a long term or a
long-distance relationship yeah no it's
just not gonna work out no she's a
sweetheart though
um let me ask you this
uh what time did she go back to her room
do you remember
oh I do
no idea you forgot yeah this one did a
month ago come on man okay all right all
right I think I can I'm just trying to
get to the bottom of this you know it's
been a big topic conversation I think I
have two huge dude uh
it's crazy how much they like I think so
right when we walked into the VMAs right
these people just love getting any type
of drama or attention or anything we
walk in there and they see who I'm with
we had seats like you know middle way up
like oh gravy we'd like to switch you to
the front we're gonna put oh they
purposely put us way up in this front
area yo dude you're smart you do have
that marketing [ __ ] I didn't choose that
they chose it I was just there for a
good time man I don't want to enjoy it
but the MILF angle got secured you that
front row seat yeah I guess so when I
brought her in there like oh no we want
you up here so we can like film you and
yeah I saw mem TV everybody posting tons
of videos about it and they're like yeah
let's get any type of intense awesome I
don't know
I guess nothing else too crazy happened
that day because there's so many things
about me I was like dude I just lost all
these dope artists get Awards it's like
Oh No One's Gonna work
that's right man that doesn't raise my
mom do you feel bad for Addison I do
because like her dad is such a [ __ ]
psycho obviously the man is like just
off the rails and then her mom joins The
Fray and you know uh I teach I feel bad
for her like
she unfollowed them both and she's like
damn me too she just just let her live
her life her parents got to steal the
Thunder her dad's pretty pretty wild I
stopped looking at the videos he's
making but they were real you know real
embarrassing
um but but you know I've reached out to
Addison and and I think she's she's
focused on other things and like yeah
maybe he needs a little break but oh
that's interesting so you talk to her
would just be like yo I just want to
tell you that I love your mom it's not
like yeah I want to make sure it wasn't
it wasn't like it was all good with her
as I mean obviously her stepdad I'm
actually I've actually known Addison for
a while she came to a meet and greet of
mine way back Ford fan before she was
popular on Tick Tock I mean she probably
had something I remember going to a meet
and greet in like 2019 and meeting these
girls that were talking about Tick Tock
it might have been her and one of the
other really popular ones like Emilia or
something but they were talking about
was tick tock tick tock app and how it's
gonna be big and I was like all right
cool well there's a picture somewhere
but that was a few years ago and okay I
help her out with music stuff she helps
me out with Social Media stuff like
that's cool oh you guys are cool like
that yeah yeah it's nice nice
yeah so I mean just did is she like The
Stepfather angle is that um
is that something you guys are have
talked about or
no no yeah I don't think I'm gonna I
don't think I'm gonna be getting uh not
making a parent mode for a while here
you know yeah people can have you know
fun dates and
um for sure absolutely so
um yeah by the way his dad her dad is
[ __ ] nuts do you really think that
like because he made that one Tick Tock
where he's like if I see gravy it's on
site or whatever and then you respond to
like don't do anything stupid grow the
[ __ ] up
are you scared of him like genuinely
doing some dumb [ __ ] if you see him in
public
I I'm not really afraid of him like
trying to fight me or something I'm just
afraid of him like really losing because
he's obviously lost his marbles and if
there's one left like I'm afraid of it
just going over the top I guess I've had
some weird stalkers in the past that
like actually were crazy and had like
bipolar I don't I don't think he's I
don't know if he's that crazy but like
people that are like in asylums now I've
been through a lot like literally three
separate times people that really were
doing this weird stalker stuff
threatening me with you know all types
of things what kind of stuff like tie me
to a chair in a basement and [ __ ] that's
what they wanted to do was share one of
them came to my to my house my mother's
house and was in the in the backyard it
was a little weird why the mon yeah but
it was kids I grew up with so anyway I
lived you know the good thing is if he's
if you're gonna get locked in the
basement I mean Cher's a good option
right who did you say locked in the
basement was in a chair
locked like sometimes I don't hear so
good bro tapes to a chair no but I also
have a weird voice taped to a chair
basement and I was like man that's just
the scariest thing I could ever imagine
I'd rather die and how did you find out
about like this this plan
these thought was they were they were
like send me voice messages of them like
breathing and like saying that [ __ ] yeah
and it was all kids that I knew when I
was growing up so they had like they
know where I lived and was it like a
jealousy thing a bitterness thing yes
jealousy things two of them wanted to be
rappers and and uh I think all of them
now are either an asylum or
um jail wow so I've been over that now
for a few years then I'm just like with
this Monty he's funny to look at but
occasionally I'll get like a bad Vibe
bad Vibe what if this becomes another
one of these yeah you know you know it's
like I'm really worried about him trying
to fight me but you know if he I don't
want him to come he's pretty Jack on the
time dad taught me to a chair or
anything no no no no no no no
anyways I think I think it's over with I
think he isn't really
I can't believe this drama this is all
real I feel like it's all real and
that's just [ __ ] incredible well I
guess what's your definition of real
because I think it's just him non-stop
posting videos about me
and people are kind of laughing and it's
real being that like you're actually you
know there's some relationship between
you and Addison Ray's mom
and that his dad is actually angry at
you this isn't like some
schtick where she like you guys reached
out in the DMS and were like yo let's do
this thing while we're dating it'll be
awesome because I could see that
happening but it does it does not seem
like that's what happened
but you are the marketing guy so I think
who knows I think he's just
um running out of
anything to do to get attention and
that's that's where his mind goes and
I mean there's no there's no no reason
why they're getting back together or
anything so I don't think it's a
jealousy thing I think it's just uh you
know attention grabber and uh it seems
like it might have ended by now we'll
see you made a diss track he did make a
diss track go check it out can we pull
that up it's in the dock I want to make
this whole thing about I guess it's just
lives we got time I got a lot of other
stuff well then you might as well I
didn't know that he made a diss track
though let me pull it up here um
Addison's Ray challenged you to a fight
here's gravy's response I saw that
uh can you guys highlight or tell me
where it is
you guys got everything prepared I like
that
the Twitter post here just tell me the
number is it okay oh it looks about
right all right don't claim me Monty you
[ __ ]
you didn't steal anyone's [ __ ] you
took his ex-wife yeah that's literally
not exactly the opposite of what
happened keep going I could help you
make a living apologize you will never
be forgiven I am Michael Jordan you are
not Scottie Pippen in the studio with
your girl
dancing I'm stealing all your hoes you
be going broke you be stealing all your
flows
sort of smooth there well not smooth but
like almost like oh yeah so he said
I'll be Dirty Dancing which is a line
from my song yeah and then he followed
it up with you be stealing all your hoes
are you sorry you'd be stealing all your
flows so it's like he literally stole my
flow and then yeah you steal your flows
but it was almost like that was pretty
was that intentional probably accidental
though yeah I think he just didn't think
about it but you know that is that is
potentially like a Rap Genius they could
be yeah like oh this is actually a
reverse if we can nurture that we could
make something of it dirty dancing I'm
stealing all your hoes you be going
broke you be stealing all your flows wow
jiggle jiggle jiggle jiggle jiggle oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
jiggle jiggle jiggle what the [ __ ] yeah
so so all all the only thing be jiggling
is Addison Ray's mom let's uh I think we
move on after this but but all I know is
that he he did reach out to a lot of of
friends of mine asking for like help
writing the song or for Beats and
everything so I don't think he wrote it
I think someone else someone else did
someone brought his ass jiggle jiggle
jiggle I mean he must have had some sort
of you know he wrote the chorus I
basically everyone that hit me up about
it was like yo do you want me to help
him out I'll give him the worst bars
and like I mean the beak it was better
than I expected because the beats that
they were showing me they were going to
send him were a lot worse I mean at
least you know dude that's that's he
didn't buy it from some website you
actually knew someone that made it for
him in that case I don't know uh I don't
know where he got the final beat from he
put the murder murder beats tag on it as
it murdered
that's so [ __ ] good man shout out you
know man he's trying well yeah anyway
you you did your top five uh MILFS for
bar stool L [ __ ] lame unoriginal idea
so I have the idea I want to give you
our top MILFs and you can kind of rate
them for us basically oh you guys have
your top five notes well I I just want
to see get your read on world famous
MILFs okay okay so here we have uh
Hillary Clinton swag
I prefer Kamala Harris but I'll take it
yeah come on yeah come on all right
you'd hit it well I'm just chilling in
Cedar Rapids
nice a lot of people say that I kind of
have a Bill Clinton swag to me oh you're
gonna left my Bill Clinton when you're
older or something
it's a weird compliment it's like weird
but Bill used to be dope and now
everyone's like uh yeah I don't really
haven't kept up but I like Bill Clinton
has mad swag though yeah he doesn't have
sweat uh G Lane Maxwell
who's that that's G Lane Maxwell
Epstein's uh Paramore Epstein's uh
accomplice of sex trafficking wow uh
yeah he's rubbing his foot that's
absolutely goodness yeah yeah
okay yeah all right so she's on my top
five all right
we like what we say no no good answer
Queen Elizabeth oh yeah the dearly
departed yeah I heard I don't pay enough
attention to all this man would you
would you desecrate her corpse
chill out man oh sorry see ya
I think I made a couple little like you
know jokes at some point about [ __ ]
Queen Elizabeth but you know
she's uh she's gone now yeah rest in
peace rest in peace I I didn't hear the
best things about her but you know
she's an icon to me and I would never
disrespect her
I would never disrespect your memory
because because I just want to desecrate
her corpse bro whenever I want to
describe her memory just her corpse
what about Queen Elizabeth the first
I don't like that head shape not good
that's that incest head shape yeah she
looks crazy man she looks like the bad
guy in Pan's Labyrinth with the fish
man that's what happens when you [ __ ]
your brother for like 10 Generations
yeah that is how they were doing it
wasn't it oh yeah
absolutely I run into that one uh Nancy
Pelosi
I don't know what she does but I've
heard her name is the speaker of the
house she's a bigger house she's kind of
a not good or good
um depends who you ask she's a prominent
politician with some big old [ __ ]
yeah
and how old is she she really actually
I'm impressed she's up there she's in
the like seven years late 70s she is 82.
I'm impressed yeah she's she can get it
she's out there on full display [ __ ]
tits uh we have uh that's uh of course
Barbara Bush she looks like she looks
like me dude
so I mean uh which yeah so maybe that's
a yes I don't know yeah
I mean she looks kind of like she'd I
think she'd be the dominant one you know
oh she'd take control for sure yeah I'm
usually you know not usually in the
other other seat but you know with her
it looks a little bit you'd submit to
her
if I was forced to uh yeah yeah
she looks like she can teach you less
she has steel eyes man those eyes those
are the eyes of a dominator what does
she like what is that facial expression
man she's ready for some she is she's
built up
um this is of course uh Betty White all
right dude that's what that's why I
named my my song after Betty yeah I
would never disrespect Betty she's a
queen if you only say anything bad yeah
shout out love her buddy uh Wendy
Williams
um
kind of a MILF status yeah just saying
yeah yeah we like it 100 okay good
that's my favorite so far uh Mother
Teresa Teresa
you know and yeah lots of controversy
around here these days but uh she was a
saint apparently so you ever [ __ ] this
ain't
uh I can't say yeah there it is I don't
know enough about religion maybe I have
there it is Mother Teresa they're
explaining their smash your pass
she's a smash yeah I need to at this
point I haven't smashed this thing yet
yeah yes smash um Wendy Williams is
number one for you that's good to know
uh this is of course uh Marjorie Taylor
green of course am I supposed to know
who that is
she's basically have you seen Attack on
Titan yes yes so she's like that she's
like The Smiling Titan yeah the smiling
the fall she's a she's a nasty evil [ __ ]
yeah she's like 30 feet tall she's a
she's just a [ __ ] design yeah but but
just I don't know she kind of looks like
like uh who's the guy rickette Rick
Blair oh Ric Flair oh interesting it's
like Ric Flair yeah but just she's I
don't like her yeah
sorry no offense Oprah Winfrey hell yeah
number one number one Oprah all day
every day my man
20 Williams number two
uh this of course is Nancy Reagan it
looks like a Star Wars character there
ah she does bro it's the hair isn't it
she looks like the captain of uh some
Starfleet yeah it's like Admiral Akbar
the eyes are kind of far apart you know
what you mean it's a prop
I like her too so Nancy so there we go
we he's feeling yeah Nancy Oprah and
Wendy one of my my favorites here wow
excellent that's loads oh this is
actually beat we actually got a an image
here oh yeah Queen Elizabeth the first
for you uh that's yeah tell me it's not
pretty accurate yeah now I see it feels
right man
uh man this of course is Marjorie Taylor
green I don't know if uh yeah all right
I'll check that out yeah yeah yeah yeah
actually kind of does look like her
thank you I have a song dropper on
Friday which is in two days uh I have a
line about Attack on Titan in there yeah
it's just tall [ __ ] I Attack on Titan
it's a woman so much I Attack on Titan I
need to find VP like Biden oh come on
Harris reference yeah I love her flip
that gold into perp right flip that perp
in a gold like a viking which is a
sports reference and then Double Cup ice
like Tampa Lightning because they got
Stanley Cups on the ice it's like a
whole like bars yeah
this is how it's done but that's uh yeah
my first line in that song is about
Attack on Titan so that's coming out on
Friday What's it gonna be called say
Lobby oh is there any um myself baby no
money in Rich Brian oh Rich Brian I'm
Afra I know him you saw a video of me
and baby no money kissing
I don't know someone sent me a clip of
y'all reacting to it it was I gotta you
taught me Utah Music Festival yeah I
think you might have rushed my rap name
a little bit but wait wait wait wait
wait wait it was it wasn't it in a
channel 5 video was it a channel five
video yes yes yes yes oh [ __ ] I remember
and we were like getting an interview
you guys were sitting on like a park
bench with me yeah money and tip okay
and uh okay yes at the end I didn't say
anything mean right no you didn't okay
good good oh this is tip I remember tip
he was all [ __ ] uh there he is a
friend of the show yeah you guys are
friends of the show I didn't realize big
tip
and then um
here's the one top uh yeah your money
yep other fella okay cool
yeah sorry I made fun of your name was
you know what I mean I take it all back
thank you I like your name thanks man
yeah
it's rewind time
take it all back there's jungle Bobby in
the corner too man good good fella
um so let's see here uh you should get
Andrew Callahan on here though he's a
friend of mine we're we we talk yeah
he's been on the show oh he has been on
it yeah oh yeah dude I love it great
dude he's taking the Internet by storm
we end up crossing paths everywhere it's
great we're at Stampede in Calgary
recently and you know he's active man
he's like he's so well
he's just he's smart and he's got that
documentary coming out that he did with
absolutely Tim and Eric's production
company about the January 6th the
Insurrection that is awesome excited for
that tuning into that also his Alex
Jones interview did that drop yet uh for
the public
I don't believe for the public but I
think it's just on his patreon yeah
so tell me about the song drop it on
Friday is there any uh previews out or
is everyone just waiting yeah yeah I got
a preview can I play it yeah I'm trying
to think of where the best I think I'll
get claimed if I play it though
um maybe I'll just you won't just hum it
for us
if I play it off my phone will it will
do that yeah we'll get [ __ ] that's
crazy how that works but yeah honestly
my label is pretty bad with the yeah
yeah yeah it's not your fault the labels
are are ruthless you say it goes It goes
uh let me live my life baby say Lobby
hey lovey
that's a good vibe man that's Friday
Friday it's like it's like a surf rock
type of vibe too it's good another one
do you dream of working with DJ Khaled
at all or not
I'd I'd love to hang out with him he
seems like a funny guy uh making music
together probably could be cool yeah why
not yeah [ __ ] DJ Khaled uh I wanna
tell me about um
I want to know like where you're where
you're from where are you born Rochester
Minnesota okay Minnesota small town
not necessarily small it's like you know
you got the Twin Cities Minneapolis St
Paul and then the next biggest city
after that is Rochester so okay 150k
people
um with the Mayo Clinic there which
people might have heard of it's like the
biggest
best hospital in the in the world pretty
much okay we're kind of like surrounded
around that hospital and yeah man it's
kind of like a
how I describe like some smallish town
just some country kids some like you
know a lot of skater kids and uh shitty
drugs and oh and um overall good place
though really good place to grow up and
um
what when did you decide like that you
wanted to start doing music when I was
in college so after I graduated from
high school I went to University of
Wisconsin Madison
and I was there for two years before I
like you know I was trying everything
like I changed my major bunch I was like
starting all these little businesses and
um
finally when I was working at that
startup accelerator and I was helping
all these companies like Market their
stuff and watching them blow up I
actually helped with with each Street
which ended up becoming like basically
what ubereats copied so like it's one of
the really early brands that was doing
that food delivery stuff I was watching
these brands do all this and I was like
man I like I played a part in that and I
think I could do that for myself so I
was a big fan of these SoundCloud
rappers and I you know just
took the time and I was I was taking a
ton of classes and I had a job and I was
running this like pizza company thing I
could get into later and then I just the
rest of my time was unwrapped man I was
really motivated you're an entrepreneur
it sounds like always hustling looking
to come up like a interesting legit
entrepreneur yeah yeah and so it's was
the rat or the rapping is that how you
would refer to it
was that uh like another entrepreneurial
angle for you yeah yeah I mean once I
started I knew that I really wanted to
do it but I had a low
confidence in the fact that it might
actually do something
so you know but I it was just fun for me
and I had like a goal to
you know at least like get big enough to
maybe interact with some of the artists
that I really liked and uh so yeah for
the first two years I didn't show my
face or anything I
was just you know grinding on Soundcloud
that was a real SoundCloud rap Era
SoundCloud YouTube everything and uh
yeah right before I graduated it kind of
blew up and
um I got a tour all set up got signed
everything and and 10 days after I
graduated I got on tour so over those
two years when you're posting on
Soundcloud was there like little
successes or did it all just happen at
once it's it's a slow it was a slow burn
bro yeah maybe no money now the dude I
was kissing on that video uh kind of
came up together from the start and
um hey man it's like you'd have a little
like group chats and you'd like send
each other yourself
for each other and like so did you have
some fans just kind of like slowly build
enough fans yeah there was a lot of
Hardcore fans even from back then that
like still come to shows like a 2017 and
earlier ones
um
and yeah man it was just a slow slow
growth but but like always exponential
it would always get faster and faster
and then and then once I dropped that
video and revealed my face and like
started really going at it it was it was
it took off Big Time interesting and um
what was it what do your parents think
about all this uh interestingly because
you went to it sounds like you didn't
really have any intention of becoming an
artist until yeah later in life and I
didn't tell
um my mom until
I didn't tell anybody really when I
first started rapping I was embarrassed
about it so I didn't tell anybody why
were you embarrassed I just didn't want
to be the guy who's like forcing music
on somebody you know mixtape okay yeah I
want to be that guy I was really
embarrassed like I I thought it was good
I liked it but I still want to force on
anybody
um so my mom actually ended up finding
finding out like from somebody else who
didn't realize she didn't know a few of
my friends figured it out I was like oh
Mom I got a long long story so how long
were you doing it before your mom found
out right a year at least in your baby
wow year and a half yeah kept that a
secret yeah man but she's a huge fan now
um my dad passed when I was 16 but I
know he'd probably be uh I'm sure he's
if looking down and and digging what's
going on here uh my mom still comes to
shows she's been to at least like 10 of
them was your mom pissed that you kept
it a secret from her for yeah not at all
she got it I mean like I think she
understood she's really we're really
tight really tight yeah were you uh I do
mind if I ask you questions about your
dad no go ahead how did he pass away uh
when I was 16 he was walking he was a
lot older yeah I had a family before my
mom started to have siblings that are a
lot older my dad was let me think he'd
be 89 now oh wow um so he was I think
seven it's almost been
yeah it's been it's been almost exactly
10 years uh 79 was walking my dog you
know Minnesota's eyes he fell hit his
head on the ice oh man and uh didn't
think much of it and then later that
night he just started getting crazy
headaches and I was at over at a
friend's house and I didn't know I was
going on my mom called me like oh Dad is
is going to hospital because he's having
you know these weird headaches and can't
see right and I don't know for some
reason I just knew I was like mass is
not not good yeah it's like I rushed
there ASAP and he had he had internal
bleeding his brain
um I just passed right that night [ __ ]
yeah scary yeah it was wild man and it
was like a
I was 16
um
kind of still figuring out who I was and
my mom like kind of shut down after she
had
um
it was really hard on her and she was
like I mean he was just her best friend
and she didn't really know where to go
forward so I kind of had to grow up
really fast and take care of the the
house and handle all this stuff and I
was trying to get into college at the
same time but it kind of it did kind of
motivate me where I was like I need to
make them proud I really want to like
you know show him that I can still do
this were you very close with him yeah
yeah you guys were tired yeah so that
must have been both like I mean
obviously losing appearance devastating
but people have different relationships
with their parents I think it'll hit
some people harder than other people so
it hit you really hard yeah yeah it was
hard but I I was in a good I guess a
good a good mindspace where I kind of
kind of use it as like motivation I was
like man like things happen he was a lot
older so I knew it was coming and then
it was like yeah well at least he didn't
have like suffer through something long
and I had like a few good friends who
had had Parents pass away and I like had
people that I could really relate to
um and just turning that into a
motivating thing rather than a a
negative thing I think helped me get
through it and
being able to support my mom like I
ended up starting that that's some of
the first business experience I had was
helping her with her business when she
was kind of like distraught was there
was there Financial issues once your dad
passed a little bit yeah not not crazy
he he worked for the Mayo Clinic but the
hospital they have good like uh
psychologist okay okay so they have good
like programs for life insurance and
everything
um
so it's a little bit but not not crazy
not crazy did you feel like you had to
like work to support like the household
though not money-wise not necessarily I
mean dude I was like a I worked at a
pharmacy and I was a weed dealer so like
I wasn't making enough money for that
but uh you were a wheel weed dealer at a
pharmacy not at the same time I was a
delivery delivery driver at a pharmacy
literally bringing drugs to people
that's what's up places but then I also
just yeah I used to sell weed too yeah
dude you know it's a good first a big
part yeah yeah definitely it was more
like emotional support for my mom and
helping her with all of her stuff
um but man yeah that was a big thing for
me but
got through it and I think you know
happy how everything came up damn
yeah good job man you did it thank you I
have definitely a lot bigger than I ever
expected like I said when I first
started rapping my goal was kind of to
interact with
some artists that I liked which was like
currency a rapper
um it's pretty Gibbs another rapper that
I like a lot and then like
I got 10 times bigger than I expected
I'm talking to them you know collabed
with my favorite artists and it feels
awesome yeah your name seems pretty like
ubiquitous ubic you you big ubiquitous
thank you lately how are you still like
aiming higher like what's your what's
your uh ambition here
I I really liked where I was at
um before Betty dropped I mean I'm very
happy where I'm at now but but it's a
little bit a little bit too much it's a
little stressful you think it's too much
Fame a little bit oh that means you're
going to become more famous
um going to like anywhere can't really
go anywhere you get recognized crazy
playing around like oh where I go and
stuff around it you get mobbed when you
go out in public yeah oh wow pretty
often especially if you stand out bro
you're like super tall stand out yeah
and how tall are you six seven
and like that's uncommon and people hear
my voice or like see my face up close
it's like pretty pretty clear
um but it but it's good man I love I
love the support and like the fans are
usually pretty wholesome usually usually
I mean some they're always good but
sometimes if it's like someone's a
little young they don't really like
understand manners
I was taking a huge bite of a Glizzy the
other day at the airport this chick
pulled up and she's like
I love you like I think you took a
picture of me don't you find it weird
when they they don't want to take a
picture with you they just want to take
a picture of you that's very rare but
when it happens I'm like I always find
that really awesome okay yeah all righty
um so so yeah man I I love a success and
it's cool to hear my song on the radio
and see like yeah new countries loving
it like I think it's number one in the
Philippines oh shout out which is cool
love that
um but uh you know I I like where I'm at
I think if I got much much bigger than
this it would be a little too much um
and I you know I don't I like what you
know I like having money and I like
having it come in but like I'm very
comfortable and I don't you know
aside from if my music gets bigger all
that there is is more money in Fame and
those cause stress so I'm chilling right
now
there it is guys you heard it from young
gravy Mo Money Mo Problems
yeah so when you're coming up though
like your entrepreneurial Spirit was it
were you looking for money or fame or
just money or just success in general as
some kind of like to prove to yourself
and maybe just thinking about your dad
it seems like that you wanted to it's
part of it be successful was it was it
uh what was it you were chasing well
we're just having a lifestyle and a job
that I could really love and enjoy you
know like I wanted to
I've always wanted to travel for work so
at one point I wanted to be a pilot and
and
do some type of work that's creative and
and you know I can work with people that
are like-minded and I ended up just you
know finding the perfect job for that
now I travel way too much you like it
you like the touring because most
artists I talk to hate it I like it I
like it but but it gets to be a lot I
mean this has been like my biggest year
of touring so far and like dude it's
it's it's crazy how many shows we end up
doing which is how many shows you've
done so far this year do you know I
think
let me think a lot of them are right
before the year at least
yeah yeah at least 100 yeah I mean I
mean within the past it's a year from
now not like in 2022 but like a year
from yeah you know what I'm saying 100
at least that's got to be nice though
getting like that that guacamole it's
it's definitely making it you know like
yeah it was definitely a little pile of
guacamole yeah yeah but I mean we got
another 40 before the year's over so
it's it's a little
a little bit much 40 more I want to say
something like that because we I think I
got a bunch of college shows this next
month and then full tour with baby no
money
smooch boy and um
I don't know I don't know what you just
said maybe no money this guy that I
smoke yeah
these names all the rappers got like
pretty wild I this is so Boomer energy
bro but it's like
I have a hard time memorizing the names
of these rappers okay Boomer money
little little gritty
Boomer money
dude we're actually a sickness I don't
know man
I can't do it but that's so Boomer of me
but yeah it's all good dude howdy 40 no
I'm 37.
these guys always make money
I'm 37. 37. all right I think it was
just you know well I know I know right
guys take that off the stream yo yo yo
guys take that off
it's just right in my line of sight I
know it's a lot of gray and I just but
I've been life's not been easy for me
man I've been a fan for a long time so
you know I just you haven't been like
you've been around you know I have been
around yeah Vape nice man Vape Nation
all day every day
yeah man
we love it so Ted how long have you been
on tip big tip come here man I want to
talk to you come here
can I no oh yeah I guess that's fine you
can chill there let's uh you look like
Anthony Kiedis you ever hear that oh
yeah that's hard
you hear must hear that all the time
right every now and then I mostly get uh
Steve Aoki nah who's that Russian dude
oh Tommy cash Tommy cash which I do not
like very much you guys have a lot in
common but you're a little pretty
thank you bro okay so so so when did you
guys start working together what's your
guys's story
um we started in like 2019.
[Music]
yeah he was he was a known DJ in
Minnesota but in a lot of shows when I
was in high school like oh I love him
okay and I went to a show that he he he
put on and I had a DJ that I kind of
came up with in Madison and then like
literally we we split up because our
girlfriends had beef with each other and
it was the dumbest thing but I'd like it
was like I had to change his contact
name in my phone damn
forbidden homie like we're like still
boys but like our girlfriends hate each
other so why did the girls hate each
other so much I was just some dumb like
Petty I couldn't even tell you exactly
why but uh so so we we part our ways for
a bit and then I needed somebody and I
hit a tip and then it was just the
perfect chemistry and we've been
so what is the relationship between you
guys exactly tip what is it you do for
gravy I just like help him with
everything like creative I guess or like
he'll ask me some like random [ __ ] and
I'll just tell him like what's good
what's bad he he did a lot of it himself
though like all of his creative [ __ ] is
him which I think is so awesome and it's
so like commendable his whole aesthetic
he made it himself like that's cool
what does that mean creative stuff do
you you how does he help you with music
and stuff I think a lot of it is is if
if
I'm too busy and something comes in I
know that tip thinks like I do so like
things will go to him first and he'll
help clean it up or like we'll kind of
on the music side so you guys want to go
no more on like Social Media stuff okay
A lot of times we'll go to the studio
together and we'll throw our ideas
together but uh but yeah I mean he's the
DJ so he does every show with me oh I
think we hang out a lot as well and work
on other things it's just like you know
big tit yeah it's like it's like when
you tour with somebody too like you
become family like right away right you
spend every day with somebody it's like
you know we fight in bicker and you know
get [ __ ] done yeah yeah
so you like touring tip is it how's that
life good for you oh you don't like it
no you like it when we're on the bus no
I no I have fun like on stage but it's
so like because I'm a homebody I like I
like being at home I I like love like
the show aspect with just the traveling
aspect is like it's exhausting it's
exhausting so like everything other than
that I love about it but like I don't
know it's it's so cool though it's so
baller yeah it is baller you guys are
living that life we just did what we do
how many people in Madison like 12 000.
damn they I think they expected 2 000
and they they put us up right by the
Capitol and then they had they had
Daughtry on the other side you know
Daughtry we faded Dodge cheating on
Dodgers it was this whole big Capital
Block in Madison but everyone kind of
crowded around my area yeah there was
there was six times as many people as I
expected that's got to feel good it was
really cool I I started tearing up at
the end because I started playing my
song Betty and they knew all the words
right away I teared up a little bit
because that's my college town so that
was where I went to college damn it's my
first Homecoming in a while that's
beautiful yeah it was really nice it was
really sick that's got to be crazy
though when you start selling shows that
big like it's just a whole nother scale
you know a lot a lot of the ones lately
have been have been wild like that and
it's it's it's cool to see that there
are a lot of new fans that'll come in
because they've heard Betty they're all
I think a big part of the crowd crowd
ends up being like the boyfriend of the
girl that's a big fan you know a lot of
stuff like that but no but there's every
show it's dope to still see all the ogs
that were like I can play a deep cutting
on other words it hasn't started the I
missed the old gravy yet nah nah there's
I'll see comments like that on occasion
it's like man like
you missed one I could literally sample
anything and put all these little exact
little things in there by breaking the
law and now I can't do that right right
yeah right it won't come out so wow
fans are cool they're supportive that's
good man I think tick tock's been a big
part of your I don't want to say success
but like as someone who's not super
connected with the music world I see
your you and people talking about you
with like the Addison Ray stuff on Tick
Tock all the time and your music too
right people sample your music a lot
there as of late when I I mean I've been
posting on occasionally on Tick Tock
because my songs have done well on there
in the past and then when Betty was
coming out I just started posting more I
was like let's just try to really push
this um which wasn't really like me I
don't like to like over saturated and
like really push something hard but I
said let's let's try it and then like it
was a good timing where like there's a
lot of these like this trend kind of
started where people would try to pitch
their moms to me and all this stuff
which was kind of funny kind of weird
but kind of funny funny yeah
um and then pick anyone up on that I did
I did actually I told you it was for a
contest that I did yeah where the it was
if you make a uh see I'm really not into
the contest thing either but I thought
I'd just try but the the number one
thing was it was like oh you pre-save
the song you make a video with it and
then like I'll FaceTime five people and
then the number one winner I'll go on a
date with their mom damn what so was
this a single mom yeah yeah okay and and
and and how old was she
37 oh wow 37 yeah that's my age bro
there's a cute video of of the date you
could probably find him okay it's very
sweet it was a sweet and then like
Addison Ray's mom did you guys uh uh
have a quiet moment in the room together
or
me and the other mom uh [ __ ] oh that's
just straight up yeah yeah you you
you're proud to say yeah I'm happy to
say I think wow hold that up I got to
see who's public information I think her
son actually like
that'd be kind of Epic to do it like at
the would be with like a thin wall to
the kids room that's [ __ ] up man come
on now look at that that's a demon laugh
dude yeah that laugh is crazy bro yeah
oh come on yo you found the video
Someone Tick Tock and it's it's uh it'll
pull it up yeah cool yeah you getting on
the MILF action or you get are you
getting left out here tip no I'm kind of
wifed up man oh you have a wife or a
committed relationship yeah yeah good
for you man yeah you got a wife right
yeah I'm married oh yeah two kids two
boys
yeah I mean I'm on that family life man
nice congrats yeah I know A lot's
happened huh thank you yeah my kids are
great I love it so much what are their
names
Theodore and Bruce
like I love the name Bruce yeah Batman I
had an alter ego uh Bruce butter crisp
that was oh I like that yeah my wife
hates because Bruce was my idea and I
love Batman and so she hates this idea
that like we named him after Bruce Wayne
so we say it's not about Bruce Wayne but
I know it is Bruce Wayne yeah there you
go but she doesn't like when I say what
are good brushes are there at the roots
there's a lot Bruce Lee Springsteen Lee
this is a strong name tons of gray
bruises but nobody's naming their kid
Bruce Bruce Willis Bruce Willis I have
the same birthday as him all right I'm
gonna put it here so it's right here
yeah so the so people can see it here
man goodness gracious um scroll down a
little
bit
uh Good Golly oh right there with the to
the right of your of your clicker with
the red one yeah there it is there it is
there it is oh [ __ ] baby it's young
gravy here with an update on the Betty
contest the first place prize went to
Jet and his mother Meredith I promised
to take the winner on a or their mother
on a date and uh here's how it went
you want to go find a romantic place to
hang out you feel me just going for a
little walk dude this is so smart
Charlie
dude what the [ __ ] you this is wild yeah
yeah update dude you guys had a good
last time
how did you know that it was going to be
like a fun MILF and not like you could
because the MILF can go a lot of
different ways you know well there was a
few I mean there was a few dope videos
that I looked at and I like kind of
have them send me the social media their
mothers and it was like like I was
picking out at the very best but then it
was like she just looked like a fun
person okay so you knew you picked the
one yeah you knew you wanted to bed
to date you get to date right right
indeed
um wow it was cute
like you guys had a really good
connection yeah we're Sun touching and
her son's a big fan too I think oh my
goodness look at the comments the sun's
in there like hyping it up too
wow I'm not throwing too much attention
to it but yeah so he has no like uh
Vengeance towards you no set it up dude
yeah you set it up he's your wing man
and he's wrapping it up man yeah so he
wanted you to [ __ ] his mom
oh yeah
well she's single and ready to mingle
why not you know sweetheart damn gravy
you live in some kind of life
okay
incredible tip what do you think about
this
I was just gonna say I think they'd
probably rather have him as a stepdad
than some you know Joe schmoe he's not
into step dad though I already tried
that
well you know I feel like an uncle a
Snapchat
Uncle gravy yes he could stand in you
know like a Time
foster dad yeah he just needs to find
the right MILF not really Foster because
you have to adopt them I don't know
foster dad we could say stepdad pseudo
Dad yeah temporary he's the dad that
stepped up man yeah but Dad that stepped
up you gonna pay for this kid's college
or what
why not
are you gonna see you're gonna start
taking care of this kid I think they're
pretty pretty well off dude that's
pretty funny man you know things keep
relationship formed maybe you never know
hey Ethan you look kind of like Bruce
phalange man
let me Google that because I don't know
anyone is you talking [ __ ] trip Bruce
he's talking [ __ ] right now
you're tripping bro
your trip now Bruce falange I don't know
how to spell let's see are you [ __ ]
bro are you serious I ain't got your ass
that looks like your aunt shell how did
you even say that that does look like
[ __ ] looks like your Aunt Shelly more
than him dog come on yeah that's fine
bro why would you even say that after I
said you look like Anthony Kiedis I know
I got you funny it doesn't really look
anything like the second one you
basically just thought of the ugliest
dude she said I look like it there's no
resemblers what about what about Shia
LaBeouf you ever get that I don't but
but that's not like insulting you're
like yo you look like a [ __ ] like
come on bro I think I look more like if
you combine us and add a little extra I
didn't know if you looked like that what
are you trying to say
[Laughter]
outdated [ __ ] uh
you picked a bad picture man yeah man
okay let me find that oh look there's a
good picture yeah right there with the
glasses I'm a smile man right below that
this one yeah okay here here yeah there
we go yeah
it looks like you're on bro I'm telling
you no it does that's [ __ ] up hey tell
him what oh my God tell them what my
aunt said on on FaceTime what'd she say
remember when when Sherry was in the car
oh what'd she say you just say it I
don't know yeah so I FaceTime my aunt
after the VMAs and she's watching the
VMAs live and Sherry's in the car she
doesn't know I'm on the phone with my
aunt
and she's like wow the VMAs were crazy
who's that old [ __ ]
and she could hear it that's funny but
she had she had a good sense of humor
and body she was like she was like oh
yeah I don't care so it's cool it's on
it's kind of crazy she's really crazy
and she apparently looks like that guy
she looks more like Bruce Blanche than
you I mean
and would she be offended by that or
cool or cool about that I think she
wouldn't like it that much but she she
has a good she roasts people that's you
know you got to take the good with the
bad with the roastage I could see the
shallow buff a little bit no I'll take
Shia LaBeouf bro just don't tell me I
look like some melted old [ __ ] like
hunk of whatever that thing was I mean
no offense I mean hey yeah come on yeah
you kind of got to get them a little
dirt I don't think he he was talking
about old school throwback
you got better pictures man you just
gotta find you gotta learn bro I looked
hard I did not see any good Bruce phalan
figures
bro I'm not gonna recover from this man
I mean he comes here calling me 49.
you're calling me Bruce flash I
graciously I graciously opened my studio
to you guys this is the respect
everybody else put the 40 up man we was
about to forget about it
it's your team man Bruce falanche good
picks
Bruce Valencia people are going to be
people are never going to drop that now
I'm Bruce phalange forever bro our fans
are Relentless like that
yeah so um all right uh what else I mean
yeah we saw the prolapse we saw the uh
Steve will do it jerks off his dog that
was crazy yeah that was crazy
kind of kind of right
uh you got any opinion about like you
follow any of these stories like Adam
Levine's I'm not I guess nope yeah you
don't care about any of that
cheated on his wife or something I
really know I find that hard to follow
was this interesting to you Olivia I
think if anyone's yeah I don't know yeah
I loved it just like what were you gonna
say I was just gonna say like why is it
I mean obviously they're not gonna pick
every single person who cheated on their
wife but like he you know go ahead he's
I guess now that I said I'm about to say
it kind of sounds negative but just
ignite
why do people care
not sounds like I'm defending him
cheating but just like like I don't go
ahead
I don't know what I was trying to get at
just you know I don't care about Adam
Levine enough to know if he's okay hold
on what about the fact that he wanted to
name his newborn son after his mistress
he asked her after they broke up
he was like what was her name you feel
about me naming my son Sumner wait so so
what was her name Sumner Sumner and then
he wanted to know if she wasn't summer
I'm positive positive and then he wanted
to name his son Sumner Summoner and
asked her permission after they broke up
like much later I guess I guess what I
was trying to say
is just
they're they're kind of just creating
more issues for the the woman you know
his wife for everyone who was who was
cheated on now it's all over and now
she's just you know that's gonna be
yeah
blowing it up on the internet a lot of
it it's true but at the same time they
should just have like a section in the
newspaper of like these are the people
that cheated this week and then I was
like if you want to go check it out you
got Adam Levine next to all the normies
hey can we have Matt Reed him flirting
like uh wasn't Adam Levine when he's
like they leaked his messages what he
said oh sure that's what's going viral
like a fanfic read real quick like you
and me I got through the girl on the go
oh I've got the I got the messages here
we can do that is this what you're
referring to yeah yeah okay all right
all right here we go it's truly unreal
no I'm Adam Levine no Matt has to be no
you can be at a living we'll let it
slide yes it is truly unreal how [ __ ]
hot you are
like it blows my mind
I mean I I think the same
seeing you in person I was like I'm
[ __ ]
no you are 50 times harder in person sex
and so am I oh my God that dude said
that about himself what a maniac
crying laughing emoji yeah no I didn't
think that
the shoulder could be intensified
yeah it's kind of getting cut off but
whoa this is a lot this is crazy the and
so am I ha ha is insane well you gotta
find the the booty one hey uh hey uh Hey
Tripp does this look like me
yeah this is a good this is a good photo
of him right this is this is a good
photo he's happy bruh okay let him live
I'm not like he can live his life come
on now it's such an odd comparison
Timmy's so dirty bro I'll never forgive
you all right
all right
um hey I found you know who's my your
celebrity look alike
yeah yeah I just I said Anthony Kiedis
originally but there's so many I
actually have one that's just right on
the money here does this remind does
this guy looks just like you bro Sloth
from The Goonies
[Applause]
you know the salacious crime salacious
Crone salacious crumb it's l-s-a-s-a-l
-a-cr
there you go
this is more oh yeah yeah I see that
especially right here is kind of my
goats yeah that's a banger yo no I see
the resemblance that's dub you know when
he's really in Demon mode that's that's
what I see this is Goblin mode tips
salacious sitting right on Jabba's
shoulder yeah man oh that's the little
dude who sat on Jabba yeah his little
buddy I didn't know he had a name
salacious crumb I think that means I
think salacious means horny and I don't
know what CR I mean salacious means like
scandalous I think or
what a salacious mean they Wanna Know
more like uh scandalous or uh yeah juicy
he looks pretty scandalous yeah that
man's seen [ __ ] Dale I'm seeing sexual
relating to sexual matters oh okay let's
see salacious uh having or conveying
undo or inappropriate interests in
sexual manners sexual dance yeah being a
horny he's a little horny Crown
a little horny Gremlin
absurd obscene little Gremlin uh tip
your response
here let's look at more of these Adam
Levine these are actually pretty epic
read some more of these let's get it
we saw this one Levine
Levine so she didn't even send the booty
yet and he said [ __ ] I made he goes I
may need to see the booty she responds
no booty
[ __ ] bro wait where did you see that it
was on another one she just flat out of
denizing I need to see this is Adam okay
this guy's like the faint most famous
dude one of the most famous dudes and
this man is he's married too bro that's
a lot and his office first is his actual
Instagram or everything he makes good
music too man that's kind of sad
[ __ ] dude
ah I mean it is kind of interesting
because look
the guy's got it all right his wife
Victoria's Secret model he's got this
amazing career he's hot family dude
insanely good looking worse tatts I
think his stats are pretty oh [ __ ] this
is the next yeah uh I'm logged into your
account so you may have not seen this
but apparently I said that to him oh he
goes responded here I said this to Adam
and he goes holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that body of yours is absurd yeah he
liked that actually lots of love for my
body on the subreddit uh the Bears were
coming out in force I'll have you know
the Bears that like like stock market
bears are like sex no bears like up from
the gay community well I think they're
saying you're a bear yes right the bear
lovers if you will the bear lovers are
coming for me call me yoga [ __ ] cause
I'll be your bear
just give you the concept you do the
rest okay amen thank you moving on
it's just the same ones oh he says how
are you such an hourglass my God
[Music]
this is so embarrassing how are you
talking like this you're a grown ass man
with the family he's talking like a damn
middle schooler
I may need to see the booty I think
that's the only one I could I maybe have
said that before you know I think
everything else the holy [ __ ] I mean
they're like holy [ __ ] that's not really
my but you know I'm I mean you know it's
more casual you know I forget the booty
it's like I may need to see the booty I
forgive it for you you're a single man
yeah you're texting you know you're on
the market everybody knows the score
I feel like he might have had some post
not Clarity after some post colloidal uh
I must say that I've had some
post-coital regrets about that phrase
Jordan Peterson you know who that is
yeah I did a um a podcast with his
daughter are you [ __ ] serious
I didn't know anything did you really
wait hold on yeah how was that it was
cool I mean it wasn't really weird at
all it was like I mean it was very um
professional like talking about like
business stuff and
um you guys talk about like um the
meaning of life or anything about
politics really did she tell did you
guys talk about all meat diet
no we didn't talk about any of that yo
30 000 views I mean come on you're
better than that I know but it was a
while ago man oh it was a while ago yeah
because she's you know it was very like
not you know I was not a fitting guest
for that particularly no not at all
that's what I found so interested it was
uh I think she was just a fan I thought
she was hot and we did it like what you
don't think she's I mean you said we did
it did you no no we did okay oh you [ __ ]
everybody you meet no I think she's
comfortable I think she's cuffs yeah
yeah she's beautiful she she only eats
meat did you know that that's right damn
I was like a fiend right there I don't
Molly you don't like it I just look like
I'm on drugs nah
it's all my eyes oh yeah everything
every place you've stopped that I look
like a I'll give you another shot here
let's see yeah man more drugs they're
getting they're kicking in by the end of
the video
[Applause]
emotions instruments and all these
things ahead of the chemistry and like
the art and oh the art I get I'd say
listen to telephone line even if you're
not in America think about it and that
that song is insane
um
yeah she's super interesting though I I
don't mean that she's coming sweetheart
no she's cool yeah
uh wow interesting
anyway a little bit uh you might say you
are having salacious thoughts about her
I'm curious now who's who's the most
like off
is off the nose I think you know
someone's on the nose they're often yeah
you can do off the nose Okay well who's
I don't think that even really fits here
anyways who's like the the weirdest or
most
unexpected person you've had on here or
oh [ __ ] surprisingly good uh we had a
guy that masturbates on feet oh he's
gonna see me man yeah the c-man we had
c-man he's a foot fetishist cool uh I
don't know if you've seen the guy on
Tick Tock he [ __ ] peanut butter he puts
his dick in peanut butter jars wow he
was a good one Kevin here he sat here
for a full hour no no no no no you just
called in I didn't walk out of Studio
got it no no no
um gosh I don't know I mean
Oh Martin scorrelli called in that was
that was good I hate him that's the one
that the guy that saw the Wu-Tang album
yeah ripped off all the cancer actually
what's interesting about that call is
that I'm pretty sure it was used as
evidence against him and poor yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no he's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah the worst people on earth I
don't know man um [ __ ] tip maybe maybe
tips the most Off the Wall unexpected
one I was gonna say Bill Burr man really
fun oh [ __ ] don't bring that up someone
hey someone else did it before me man
yeah I had so so there's there's deep
lore Bill Burr came on it was like the
worst [ __ ] Show interview it was just
horrible
and uh that that was like my lowest
moment on podcast history well you guys
like not agree with stuff you've been
looking at that Vape a lot again is
there is there substance yeah I mean not
not wheat not pot no it's just it's like
Vape Nation man it's just Vape Nation
yeah there's so it's just it's just uh
yeah
yeah I'm not gonna get high no yeah
I wouldn't do that because we're we're
gonna Vape up cheers bro all right oh
[ __ ] it up
[Music]
we can rip it fatter oh yeah it tastes
like headshots
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I found these just kind of laying around
my house like in the studio we have but
I cleaned them off so don't that's right
I
yeah yeah I believed you man I I went in
there with trust thanks man
all right well um
never I I wish we had more Adam perfect
to read or or questions to ask me
is it that awkward yeah all right well
actually here we have actually we've had
a great moment with the Vape so I wanted
to follow it up something hot here let
me see if people if chat has um
Chad has anything to say how can you
read the chat and it's fast it's fast
but I think sometimes it catches up and
it looks faster than it is
a kiss that's the first thing I saw
okay we want to do a peck yeah we got
kisses uh I'll pack you we got kisses on
kids
[Music]
I give you a peck
oh my God you guys what what is this
it's uh great for socials
all right do I put my arm around you oh
yes
and just a pack right no tongue yeah but
you're looking at me so intimately bro
don't treat me like one of your MILFs
you guys can't see his hands on my leg
it's not even on camera yo treat me like
one of your mouths kiss me like a milk
oh my God
interesting
[Applause]
sorry I'm just uh bit smitten here
my goodness
all right we're gonna ask you if you can
name your next kid gravy now I know yeah
I just had a gravy minute there
salacious
yeah I would come on too oscillations oh
we need to have a pride minute after
that you're right yeah let's have a
pride minute here
this is the minute
where everyone could be proud to be them
true selves you know we support lgbtq
rights trans rights all that we heavily
believe in that here and there's just so
much there's so much homophobia so much
transphobia in the world
that I think is important to give
everyone one minute that's it to express
themselves be proud of themselves to uh
you know uh and to just feel like come
out of the closet you know see the fresh
breathe the fresh air
run on the Green Pastures you know the
weather's fine you're a normal human
don't be ashamed it [ __ ] everybody who
tells you
that who you are isn't right
also I'm sure you've said this because
you live in like a small town and you
don't feel comfortable go to like
Atlanta neighborhood or go to like the
gay Brotherhood the West Hollywood
neighborhood and you will
they have a coolest
there it is man just leave bro just or
just go visit and you'll see that it's a
very common thing yeah check it out yeah
yeah you know okay okay I'm not gay no
more yeah so Pride minute is over all
right everybody back in the [ __ ]
closet shame on you
uh you guys disgust me
you are an Abomination back in the
[ __ ] closet free shame on you and you
know what
being gay is a choice that you made to
in the face of God
in the closet you with me gravy nah
Jesus said no I'm not gonna go there
with Grace
um
yeah
there's a um
there's somebody in the uh call Lobby
that uh I wanted to call in I don't know
if you want to set that up a little bit
my grandma texted me so Olivia's Grandma
texted she's I guess she may have seen
some of this and so your grandma's
calling Olivia your grandma's okay
that's a good thing for artists who come
oh okay we've talked to her grandma
before she's a character sometimes she
calls in we have a rule that whenever
she calls him we have to talk to her no
matter what's happening so let's bring
on um she look like you I don't know
let's see
hey uh Nana how are you
nana I don't know Grandma is gonna call
you Nana
uh I'm Grandma treat that's right I'm a
tree
treat I guess so I'm here with a young
gravy the gravy train hello beautiful
you're bouncing cannot hear you oh oh
you can't shoot you can you hear us uh
hello
I'm here but every time you talk I get
like vibration is that is that possibly
on her and Dan yeah it could be I think
it's working fine earlier can you hear
me okay
oh this is bad news no it sounds like
you're playing an electronic piano
I think you're getting Echoes what I
would assume and not and not in a good
way
very good grandma treat everybody you
look great listened you like your art
wait we gotta figure this out we gotta
we gotta try to figure this out get her
on the phone just call her on the heroes
you leave the video up mute your speaker
Grandma treat and then I'll talk to you
on the phone how's that sound she can't
even hear me I got her number arable
it's Josh I was like yo what this guy's
[ __ ] with everybody
just being silly man you being a silly
it's goofing
uh give me a kiss again bro
[Laughter]
give it give me the give me the yeah
just pass it here we have to always talk
to Grandma tree it's the part of the
rules of the show thank you hey Grandma
treat just leave your video on and mute
your speaker I think you're just having
a feedback issue
all right hang on yeah
not real well
you ever play tech support for mouse
because sometimes it's like uh
you know there's a need yeah nice little
effort
once we had a guy on called the cougar
champ Kyle the cougar champ he only
[ __ ] Grant like old ass grandmas is
that something you're into or no
I can't say I haven't really experience
so I'm not sure yeah I'm not sure
good for him though
he was crushing it good that guy was
cleaning up dude yeah wow good for him
because it's not a competitive market
yeah
uh Grandma are you there
yeah I'm trying to connect back into
those well no no we'll just talk on the
phone we'll just talk on the phone it
works
isn't it don't speak it is thicker it's
quiet it's a lot of the kids all right
Grandma uh thank you so much it's been a
pleasure
that's it is that it well I don't know
how do I have the conversation it's not
working what's up grandma what's up the
gravy what's up treat okay I'm gonna
hang on
oh God I can't even join on on just
speak to us on here to speak to us on
the phone let's get it
great
actually I sound like Bill Clinton I
usually hear Barry White but I'll take
that too nice thank you I I go around
the world with you oh amen yeah yeah
your grandma is kind of acting up here
Olivia every time
yeah if we wanted to yeah I mean
anything Barry White talks about I'm
down for that wait you're six seven and
you've got a deep voice what could be
wrong with this picture I can't think of
anything
music to my age Olivia your grandma's
[ __ ] what are you doing later yeah
are you in L.A goodness I am
oh wait does the speaker come out of
here wait what's this song bottom where
does the sound come out look at your ass
Jesus goodness yeah all right have some
respect this is uh no she said some very
respectful things a moment ago I don't
know if y'all heard him okay it was cute
or maybe it's just for me
is that coming through you can literally
just put it on there
well Grandma treat and I are discussing
a date later what the [ __ ] you are
already that took like 10 seconds I
didn't even hear what she's saying she
said she said
a second wait a second I got a question
what's a girl gotta do to get into a
music video with you into a music video
[Music]
no no that's post date you know first
okay okay I mean you got to tone it down
you're already fighting to get in a
music video Grandma bro she's always
good I got I've got it I forgot a good
idea
videos she's not a cloud Goblin I mean
it'll start out with a different sort of
goblin
I am not I am not bad yeah I know I I am
was in front of me silly there I uh we
love to connect
let's do that I'll show you my artwork
amazing that you got to see for a second
oh gorgeous
well thank you treat all right treat
listen uh I'm not trying to put Olivia
in this awkward position I appreciate
you calling in but I'm definitely not
trying to have you [ __ ] young gravy dude
total [ __ ] block well I mean listen I
mean uh
Olivia should have some say in there
oh this no I've had just about enough of
my grandma all right for right now all
right treat it's been a treat I feel
like
wow no I love you Grandma I'll see you
later
uh yeah I got colder for two weeks did I
hear from you no
ouch oh you know what that is my bad
that is my bad oh I've been at the bad
side so sorry I'll bring you I'll bring
you something this week
oh yeah I'll bring you something tonight
I'm just kidding I'm sorry
[Laughter]
bring something tonight yeah yeah bring
something tonight
you've got a great voice you've got a
really fabulous voice thank you I really
appreciate that yeah it's been real all
right yeah is there anything else you
guys want to say before I hang up this
is out of control
that's not out of control we haven't
even gotten started
amen amen what you got Grandma give it
come on
I think I think we've you know Russ
comes later we haven't been down this
road before
all right listen uh grandma have
yourself a great day
and um thanks for calling okay we'll be
in touch yeah you will not be in touch
uh with uh the gravy train okay looked
elsewhere Thank you Grandma talk to you
soon
because that woman is up what a sweet
Relentless you're a sweetheart it's
usually like that
yeah sometimes yeah she comes on strong
[Music]
wow sometimes okay that's a little
[ __ ] up I thought I was special all
right no you are she I mean she doesn't
come on to me like that [ __ ] yeah she
doesn't talk to me like that
well all right well uh that's about I
mean what else dude you what else we got
um
Adam Levine that was good
we'd love to see that
because
did you hear that um I Heard yeah this
shit's kind of nut Ray J yeah yeah I
don't totally understand but it sounds
crazy so the Kardashian sex tape
that she shot with Ray J
apparently they like sold the
distribution rights to like a big porn
company
I didn't know that
I thought it was contract were like
basically the mom wanted it to happen so
the story that Ray J is saying is that
they shot the first porn and her mom
reviewed it said it's not good enough
and made her shoot another two
is that a lot yeah I mean that's wow
yeah honestly
like I can't even relate I have a sex
tape leaked and I can't related anyway I
said
baffling okay so this is actually
interesting so
Kris Jenner went on a polygraph test on
James Corden show and he asked the
question about her involvement with the
release of the tape she denies having
any involvement with the with the
release of the sex tape the man who's
running this test
is a [ __ ] scammer bro
he's a total fraud This Guy's in every
YouTube channel
when James Charles stole our Teddy fresh
hoodie this is the [ __ ] that did
the polygraph closed captioning not
available
and what she informs Kim the tape made
1.4 million I'm surprised that was it
in 2007 when it was first released
though it's okay yeah I mean it made a
lot more sense then
yeah but that's so [ __ ] up because
their story was always that it got
leaked isn't it yeah and so they were
getting paid off on the back end the
whole time her mom
damn well she filed a lawsuit against
the distributor claiming she didn't
authorize the release but then it was
shown in some emails uh I believe a few
months later that they were sending her
receipts of how much money it made dude
there it is so your mom her mom's her
pimp I love that her mom is a business
woman I guess I mean if you're gonna
have a pimp why not your mom right you
know you can trust her that's crazy
sentence I'm just saying I'm trying to
look for the yeah right side there well
um there it is folks young gravy yes
he's everywhere
you're on tour right now people can buy
tickets yes I have a tour while I'm
doing a bunch of college shows right now
which are kind of private but but uh
November and December myself and baby no
money doing uh US and Canada punishos
and then I think I got Australia and
Asia in the
in the early next year where do they go
to buy tickets they would go to just
look up young gravy anything if you want
to find me on whatever just look up
young gravy and then tickets or
Instagram or yeah whatever it is yeah I
don't know a huge single coming out this
Friday exciting Celine
we're gonna be jamming that
it's been a good time man first time
I've ever kissed a man yeah whatever the
one and only wow we're running a
romantic uh beautiful we're having a
romantic moment yeah man surprise Ela
didn't call in yet
yeah I want to say it I want to say Hi
man
[Music]
every time I stream on Tick Tock I get
banned for what it's a little crazy oh
actually it says internet air so this
time it wasn't the tater tots uh the all
the Andrew take kids are always
um oh no wow yeah they don't like me no
they still exist the entertain kids Yeah
man they [ __ ] love him he's their man
call him the tater tots tater tots
that's insane man yeah let me call you
for real I'm doing Jimmy Kimmel tomorrow
too which is fun you are yeah fine if
anyone wants to tune in tune in tomorrow
night oh
hey I'm here with young gravy Ella he
wanted to say hi and also I just wanted
to
I wanted I didn't want you to hear this
from somebody else I wanted you to hear
from me and not see it online that um
I'm kind of embarrassed and ashamed to
say this but uh me and gravy kissed
yeah we did
it was it was great it was great it was
cute I I initiated
it was just a it was just a pack I mean
I didn't move my lips but he did one of
these
yeah
I just
at first I didn't I didn't realize there
was a child I thought that was her at
first the kids don't seem happy
uh Bruce has
a lot yeah I'm sorry
all right Angie sounds like you have
your handful I'm sorry yeah
that's um
no no no I said explicitly no tongue oh
babe
yeah I'm sorry but okay so that that's
what it is so um anyway
I did like it I just want to say that
I just want to be totally transparent
oh but it's like that one
all right uh you did you want to say
anything else to uh yeah uh thank you
for understanding and I'm uh hope to
meet you someday
yeah if you're worried about
um Monty you better [ __ ] watch your
back first oh yeah absolutely
I know I already know
yeah exactly right now
yeah let's do it
all right I'm gonna take off my shirt
and start screaming
that sounds scary all right listen uh
we're about to wrap it up so I'll see
you soon
okay love you
absolutely you got it
all
right
bye hey you know what what did
Fouseytube think about that kiss uh Zach
I felt worthless
I felt ugly
I felt gay
I felt that no like that just based on
what they told me it's a it's so it's
such a deep layered joke that I'm sorry
to even put you through that
Matt you would [ __ ] with fousey too man
yeah he's funny as hell you think so
he's a goofball man it tastes like beef
jerky
anyone tastes like beef jerky I feel
like if I had a you look like a little
slab of human beef jerky yeah I like
that listen I had a lot of fun me too it
was a really good time thanks for being
here thanks man you know really great to
meet you I'm happy for all your success
I love your music it's super unique and
interesting I can tell you're just
having fun absolutely I mean the hits
great
good you don't believe me no no I
believe you I believe you you sound like
you're starting a sentence you know oh
you haven't heard or you
no I think it's great good thank you
obviously I'm obviously a lot of people
do you know thank you I think you're
gonna be I think you're gonna get so
famous that you hate it
I already do so we'll see even more I
think you're going all the way we'll see
that gravy train those are good things
too so
here she goes would you ever consider
dropping a sex tape with Addison Ray's
mom because I think that could be
something that could be uh that could do
a lot of uh units went through that
whole thing and it was stressful and I'm
good man I'm chilling have sex in
private
um members go up thank you for the
gifted thank you for the 50 gifted uh
tip it was nice meeting you as well good
to meet you too man uh I always wanted
to meet a a Sloth from The Goonies good
guy lovable character it looks more like
sloth from uh Ice Age honestly oh that's
true
yo how many you look like all the sloths
sloths sloth from Ice Age
no I think the most accurate one that I
pulled up was uh he's getting to he's
getting a nut and him and I look like uh
me and him look like Gumby and Gumby's
horse that's that's the closest I've
really gotten yeah
we started a whole little thing about
this but yeah man do you like being
Pokey tip or no no do you not see the
resembles a little bit yeah I do I don't
like it I see it that's whack that's
accurate man look at that I'm muting
myself wait hold on let me see tips pull
him up again
yeah I see the resemblance bro I don't
know like the hair color I don't know
the it's all there dude but Gump Gumby
was Gumby was the man and his horse was
a good guy too you know they had a good
thing yeah they're Legends good team I'm
Bill Clinton yeah they didn't do [ __ ]
bro what did they do for the community
bro they never did nothing
[ __ ] around all day what did they do
bro what do you guys do other than [ __ ]
MILFs we do cool things man come on dude
we don't need money I mean for the
community
am I off am I off Target here no what do
you do for the community Matt provides
happiness for people you say Gumby does
it why you gonna put Gumby down hell no
he's from gummy I think yeah not you
yeah why you gotta put Gummy down Gumby
down bro he don't do [ __ ] you never
heard of them what the youth doesn't
know about Gumby
that's probably true see come on now but
at one point he meant a whole lot he was
balling out for sure fell off yeah
somebody did fall off I'll lose it
should have put the horse you know
Lumbee put the horse on me now but it
was really fun time guys really fun I
wish all the best for you guys and see
you again soon hopefully yeah uh um
let's come to a show you're in L.A right
oh yeah that'd be great I'm gonna I mean
I won't be in La for a really long time
it was a tour but busy busy I do have a
show here everyone's wrong it's um
December 4th I think
at the
the Palladium Palladium
it's not a big one it's decent like 3
000 maybe yeah okay can I come on stage
and say yeah hell yeah yeah okay okay
let's do it can we kiss again or do baby
kiss on stage oh yeah man I can bring
the 50 battery Vape uh yeah we have the
backpack one have you seen that yeah
let's get it you just like dance around
stages the whole time hitting the Vape
it's super heavy but I can manage it for
a little bit all right actually it
weighs like 100 pounds it's kind of like
insane yeah it's a lot of battery a lot
of Hardware huge clouds I bet
the fattest man shot dude insane [ __ ]
um there it is young gravy and little
tip
[Laughter]
yeah baby so much fun look him up he's
on Tick Tock he's on tour they're
everywhere and they're crushing it
thanks thank you thank you for having us
really fun time great guys good people
love you man treat uh if you want to get
up with treat we can you guys can talk
with uh it's up to Olivia's number
yeah thank you members go up yeah
they're still watching people are
watching are people still watching us
right now yeah oh you're saying did we
end it yet oh yeah okay so yeah anything
up about me whatever you want just it's
y-u-n-g gravy not not y-o-u that's the
only thing that really trips people out
but if you search young gravy with just
the you about me wherever
young gravy
was that just like the street way to do
it or why didn't you spell it like young
why UNG why did I make a difference yeah
just because I thought I thought it
would stand out it was it looked better
visually and and uh one of my favorite
rappers is Young lean oh yeah spelled it
that way was it that way and I just was
like I want to do it this way man have
you met young lean I've met young Lin uh
I know him you look forward to it did he
had I've tried to go over shows a few
times and every time he has a show in
Minnesota that someone calls a bomb
threat what it's been like four times
yeah I mean I I assume he's done one
since then but that was when I like was
able to go to show are you guys is he
aware of you you guys talk I I think he
likes one of my messages once which to
me it was like huge he's a very like
anti-social person but that's funny I
yeah I know I know a young glean you
ever drink lean is that you and I tried
it I think it was that special it's just
drinking like cough medicine right like
NyQuil like no not really I mean it's
like a lot of different NyQuil but it it
is a cough medicine it's kind of like
similar to an opiate you reference that
on C'est la vido you I did say something
about it oh I said I said double I wrap
for that line I said earlier Double Cup
ice with the with the Tampa line I said
Double Cup but ain't no lean I only sip
syrup when I'm with Chief Keef oh okay
nice you hang out with you and then I
said I play clean PC I pipe Christine PC
I pipe correct I'm so PC wow peas and
C's you know
people look at the surface level man he
wants unbelievable Chief Keef is a great
guy yeah get him on here that'd be
awesome okay great fella and uh we can
maybe we'll work on the young Link
connection that's important that'd be
awesome what's so lean you have to get
from a doctor right you need a script
for that yeah it's really hard to get it
otherwise and it's really expensive and
I tried it I'm over it it's only my
thing you need to drink a whole bottle
of that [ __ ] is that how it works it's
not like you ever do like Robo tripping
is that what you uh no I know what it is
though no I haven't done Robo tripping
I listen I admitted to smoking crack on
the show all right all right I'm not
trying to download Robo tripping is
Lamer than crack I think I don't know
have you smelled crack no I haven't
smoked I tried it once [ __ ] math it
was not cool oh I haven't tried math
that sounds crazy I think we should yeah
let's just not not do either oh yeah no
I'm good now Robo tripping is you just
drink a full bottle of Robitussin that
was like high school [ __ ] right yeah
yeah yeah I had homies who did that so
you just hit a whole bottle of
Robitussin and then I mean what does
that make you do it I never sleep I
never really felt much man I thought my
friends were like acting like [ __ ]
wolves right I was just I just hit it
and I like felt kind of weird yeah I
wouldn't recommend that no no no no no
um
meth what was that like
pretty wild you got like super blasted I
didn't know I didn't know
the first time I did meth sounds crazy
twice two times on accident the first
time I I sworn in the line I thought was
coke before my first show ever and it
ended up being meth and it was like dude
I was like how was the show off the wall
it was good but I was so hyper and like
screaming my lyrics I have kind of chill
lyrics and I was just like really really
hyped up like I had I had a good time
but I feel like that was good yeah so
meth is good first though but I felt
like [ __ ] for for days after yeah yeah I
don't think math is good yeah no math
and the second time you did man second
time I did math it was it was I was
hitting a a ball that was weird it was
it was math and I think I call that a
Sherm a Sherm stick because when they uh
stick and then they combine weed and
masks and that was just weird I was like
oh I know I just hit something different
that tasted weird and that wasn't crazy
but I was like I don't know why I just
it's a little sketchy when you're like
with that many people and everyone's
passing yeah it was like just a few
people uh I've actually to be honest
I've heard I know a lot of people who
were like just chilling thought they
were gonna like smoke weed and then like
it was like heroin or something yeah
gotta be careful crazy dude it was it
was this this gay fellow that was on um
house arrest for selling math okay
handed me math and he was like hit this
and uh interesting I did and I'm I was
like yeah that wasn't weird I was like
oh all right he like intentionally
tricked you no I mean I don't know maybe
I don't know interesting that's really
[ __ ] up yeah but I mean let's keep him
on house arrest let's not let him out I
want to see me probably just keep him in
there okay well there it is guys no math
no crack and certainly no Robo tripping
yeah any drugs you do recommend
DMT really
I think everyone should try it once it's
really cool if you think you can you
know if you're down with psychedelic
stuff I'd recommend DMT you how many
times you've done DMT a lot oh really a
lot yeah it's a short thing like it
barely lasts it lasted 10 minutes so
it's easy so what what is it you look
for when you do it
we mean well like sometimes you'll do
drugs like if you do MDMA you're like
looking for this like euphoric happy
High you smoke weed to relax stuff like
that you know you get drunk you're
having a good time at a party like what
is it because I know it is short lasting
what is it you're looking for in the
experience when you take DMT just like
get away like dude in private or like
with a couple friends and it's just a
crazy it's it's kind of just
to see what your brain's capable of
basically because crazy [ __ ] that's
going on and it's like it's just
interesting it's pretty cool so it's a
it's just a psychedelic do you found it
you find uh like insights into yourself
through doing DMT or it's changed you in
some way I don't think the Mt no no it's
too quick and it's too crazy it's like
all this [ __ ] happening at once and then
you just wake up it's not scary like I
think I have had sort of realizations on
like shrooms and stuff and I think there
are you know there's some good
good things that people can learn on
psychedelics but DMG is kind of just a
cool experience to try out and
you don't feel scared on DMT it seems
scary to me
that's a lot of people say then they try
it and it's kind of like well still not
that bad I don't know I recommend trying
it there it is DMT for the opportunity
there it is will you do DMT before the
show if I come
I mean it'll be gone I used to do it
before I'm meet and greets and and
really yeah but it was just a bit of
relax though I would hit him he could
have like a cool like trip experience
then I would meditate then I would go to
my meetings oh no I'm saying go up there
high on DMT well it's gone by the time I
you know it'll be gone already
how short is that I thought it was like
10 minutes if you like really like Blast
Off you like fall asleep and do a whole
it's not everything but like if I just
hit the hit the DMC a little bit went on
stage I'd I'd by the time the first
songs over I'd be sober
I'd love to see that all right set that
up do it yeah
that's interesting I'm down so there it
is guys there it is I think we should
stick to G fuel
stop
do you know they put lead in there
[ __ ] [ __ ] do you feel if it's lead in
there or well I'll say I don't know if
they put it in there but there is lead
in it
this tastes like Baja blah pull that up
look how much you drink that's the real
[ __ ] right there oh it disappeared
in front of my shirt no that's not how
that works is it it's gonna be green no
matter what I drink most of it there it
is guys
thank you alrighty take care everybody
thanks for watching we'll see you on uh
tomorrow morning
with Hassan
we have a lot to talk about you know
Hassan [ __ ] see the America deserve 9
11.
oh my God nope no all right thanks for
watching everybody
[Music]
thank you